>>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH! WOW!
HELLO EVERYBODY. HELLO TUDUM!
HELLO BRAZIL! HELLO TO EVERYONE
WATCHING AROUND THE WORLD AND
TUNING IN! I'M CHRIS HEMSWORTH
AND I AM THRILLED TO OFFICIALLY
WELCOME YOU HERE TODAY. AFTER
TWO YEARS OF THIS GLOBAL FAN
EVENT TAKING PLACE VIRTUALLY, I
KNOW I CAN SPEAK FOR ALL THE
GUESTS THAT WE HAVE HERE TODAY
WHO ARE SO EXCITED TO BE HERE.
TO BE HERE LIVE IN THE CITY
THAT STARTED IT ALL. SAO PAULO,
BRAZIL. HOME TO THE LOUDEST
FANS IN THE WORLD, AM I RIGHT?
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I'M GOING TO
SAY THANK YOU TO OUR GRACIOUS
HOSTS IN THIS BEAUTIFUL CITY.
THEST BEEN INCREDIBLE. I LOVE
YOU ALL, THANK YOU VERY, VERY
MUCH. AND NOW TO KICK THINGS
OFF, I WANT TO TALK ABOUT MY
BRAND NEW FILM THAT JUST
DROPPED NOT NETFLIX,
"EXTRACTION 2". AND I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU SINCERELY FROM
THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART. THE
FANS AND THE SUPPORT FROM THE
FIRST FILM. WE WOULDN'T BE HERE
WITHOUT YOU. SO THANK YOU!
THANK YOU SO MUCH! YOU KNOW,
THIS  ACTION-PACKED SEQUEL TO
"EXTRACTION" IS SO MASSIVE THAT
I BROUGHT SOMEONE HERE TO SAO
PAULO TO HELP ME TELL YOU ABOUT
IT. SO PLEASE, A WARM WELCOME
TO MY GOOD FRIEND WHO IS A
FEARLESS VISIONARY DIRECTOR OF
"EXTRACTION 2", SAM HARGRAVE!
>> WOW! THIS IS AMAZING!
>> THIS IS SOMETHING ELSE, I
HAVE TO SAY.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
EVERYONE WHO MADE "EXTRACTION"
SUCH A HUGE HIT ON NETFLIX.
WHAT A JOURNEY IT'S BEEN.
>> ONE HELL OF A JOURNEY.
>> TO BE HERE FOR THE RELEASE
OF EXTRACTION 2 IN TUDUM IS
SOMETHING WE NEVER EXPECTED.
BUT I AM SO HAPPY TO SAY TYLER
RAKE IS BACK!
>> BACK FROM THE DEAD!
RESURRECTED! I HAVE TO SAY, I'M
SO GRATEFUL THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
CONTINUE THIS JOURNEY THAT WE
BEGAN. IT WAS SIX YEARS AGO
WHEN WE SHOT THE FIRST FILM.
AND BACK THEN, WE SET OUT TO
CREATE AN INTENSE EDGE OF YOUR
SEAT THRILLER. ABSOLUTELY
LOADED WITH ACTION. AND WITH
THIS NEW MOVIE, WE HAVE TAKEN
IT TO THE NEXT LEVEL AND
BEYOND. AND SAM, I GOT TO TELL
YOU, WHY DON'T YOU TELL
EVERYONE WHAT THEY ARE IN FOR?
WHY DON'T YOU TELL THIS
BEAUTIFUL AUDIENCE WHAT THEY
CAN EXPECT FROM OUR FILM?
>> WELL, AFTER BARELY SURVIVING
THE EVENTS OF THE FIRST FILM,
TYLER RAKE IS BACK AS THE
AUSTRALIAN BLACK OPS MERCENARY
TASKED WITH ANOTHER DEADLY
MISSION. RESCUING THE BATTERED
FAMILY OF A RUTHLESS GEORGIAN
GANGSTER. IN THIS FILM WE TRIED
TO MAKE THE ACTION BIGGER,
BOLDER, AND EVEN MORE INTENSE
WHILE DIVING INTO THE EMOTIONAL
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
CHARACTERS. SO, CHRIS. WHAT WAS
IT LIKE FOR YOU TO STEP BACK
INTO THE SHOES OF TYLER RAKE?
>> IT WAS AMAZING. I LOVE THIS
CHARACTER. I LOVED IT THE FIRST
TIME I PLAYED IT. THE SECOND
TIME WAS EVEN MORE FULFILLING.
I WAS SO THRILLED TO STEP BACK
INTO THIS CHARACTER. WHAT'S
REALLY EXCITING, I'M EXCITED
FOR PEOPLE TO SEE IS THIS FILM,
WE GET TO TAKE A CLOSER LOOK
INTO THE BACK STORY OF TYLER
RAKE'S MOTIVES. THE FIRST FILM
TOUCHES ON IT. BUT THE SECOND
FILM DIVES MUCH DEEPER. SO I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO LOVE IT.
>> NOW, SAM, THANK YOU! THIS
IS THE MAN WHO CREATED THIS
INCREDIBLE FRANCHISE. SAM. I'M
GOING TO SAY, ONCE I SAW THE
FILM IN THE POST PRODUCTION
PERIOD AND ALL THE INCREDIBLE
WORK YOU HAVE DONE, YOU BLEW ME
AWAY. THIS IS SECOND TO NONE.
YOU'VE OUT DONE YOURSELF. I'M
GOING TO SAY THANK YOU, MATE,
I'M SO PROUD OF IT.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE SEEN
THE FIRST FILM BUT IN THE
MOVIE, WE DID SOMETHING. WE
CALL IT A ONER. WHICH IS AN
EXTENDED SEQUENCE OF LONG SHOTS
TO APPEAR AND BE EXPERIENCED
LIKE ONE LONG SHOT. BUT IN THIS
FILM, WE KNEW WE HAD TO TOP
OURSELVES. SO WE WENT OUT AND
CREATED A 21-MINUTE ONER THAT
IS GOING TO LEAVE YOU ON THE
EDGE OF YOUR SEATS. IT'S EVEN
LONGER AND MORE COMPLEX. WE
TRIED TO CREATE AN IMMERSIVE
EXPERIENCE WITH A NON-STOP
THRILL RIDE. AFTER MANY MONTHS
OF PLANNING AND REHEARSAL AND
FIVE WEEKS OF SHOOTING, I THINK
WE PULLED IT OFF. NOW CHRIS, I
THINK THESE PEOPLE MIGHT WANT
TO KNOW HOW IS SHOOTING THAT
SEQUENCE FOR YOU?
>> EXHAUSTING! I'VE GOT TO SAY,
SHOOTING THE ONER, MOST OF THIS
FILM WAS KIND OF SIMILAR TO HOW
THE AUDIENCE MIGHT FEEL WHEN
THEY WATCH IT. IT WAS
RELENTLESS ACTION THRILL RIDE.
WE HAD MONTHS AND MONTHS OF
REHEARSALS WITH MYSELF, STUNT
PERFORMERS, SAM. AS I SAID, WE
WANTED TO TAKE IT SOME PLACE
THAT WAS UNEXPECTED AND TAKE
OURSELVES TO A PLACE WE HAD
NEVER BEEN BEFORE. IT WAS
BRUTAL, IT WAS EXHAUSTING BUT
THE MOST REWARDING THING I HAVE
EVER DONE. I THINK WHAT YOU
WILL SEE ON SCREEN IS SOMETHING
THAT HAS AN AUTHENTICITY AND A
GRIT THAT IS TRUTHFUL. 90% OF
WHAT YOU SEE IN THIS FILM WAS
SHOT IN CAMERA ON THE DAY. IT'S
NOT SPECIAL EFFECTS. IT'S NOT
POST-PRODUCTION. SAM HAD
HELICOPTERS LANDING ON MOVING
TRAINS. 400 PEOPLE IN FIGHT
SEQUENCES. THE FURTHEST I HAVE
EVER GONE. THE MOST REWARDING.
WE DID IT FOR YOU GUYS, YOU
FANS, TO GIVE YOU SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
>> WELL, CLEARLY, TYLER IS A
CHARACTER PEOPLE WANT TO SEE
MORE OF. THE RESPONSE FOR ALL
OF YOU FANS HAS BEEN OFF THE
CHARTS. THANK YOU! FOR ALL OF
YOU WHO HAVE BEEN FLOODING OUR
SOCIALS WITH THEIR SUPPORT.
>> WE WOULDN'T BE HERE WITHOUT
YOU. SO THANK YOU SO, SO MUCH.
I LOVE YOU ALL. HONESTLY, THIS
IS THE WARMEST WELCOME WE HAVE
EVER RECEIVED. YOU GUYS ARE
INCREDIBLE. NOW, I KNOW WE HAVE
ONLY JUST RELEASED "EXTRACTION
2". BUT IS ANYONE INTERESTED IN
SEEING MORE OF TYLER RAKE IN
THE FUTURE? WHAT? I CAN'T HEAR
YOU. MORE? MAYBE? LET'S HEAR
IT. COME ON. WELL GUESS WHAT?
BECAUSE BETWEEN US, US FRIENDS,
WE ARE ALREADY TALKING ABOUT
"EXTRACTION 3" THANKS TO THE
RESPONSE.
>> THANK YOU BRAZIL! MAKE SURE
TO CATCH "EXTRACTION 2"
AVAILABLE ON NETFLIX NOW!
>> I LOVE YOU ALL! YOU GUYS ARE
THE GREATEST!
>> WOW! FIRST AND FOREMOST,
GIVE IT UP FOR CHRIS HEMSWORTH
AND SAM HARGRAVE!
>> I'M MAISA.
>> I'M CHASE STOKES.
>> AND I'M MAITREYI
RAMAKRISHNAN.
>> AND WE ARE SO PUMPED TO
BRING YOU TUDUM 2023 LIVE FROM
BRAZIL!
>> DID YOU GUYS KNOW THIS YEAR
MARKS THE 10th ANNIVERSARY OF
ORIGINAL PROGRAMMING ON
NETFLIX?
>> WOW. SO JUST IN TEN YEARS,
WE'VE GOTTEN SHOWS LIKE SQUID
GAME.
>> WEDNESDAY.
>> AND OF COURSE, STRANGER
THINGS!
>> SO WE'LL BE OUT HERE ALL
NIGHT LONG WITH DOZENS OF YOUR
FAVORITE NETFLIX STARS TO GIVE
YOU DROPS FROM SOME OF YOUR
FAVORITE NETFLIX SERIES AND
MOVIES.
>> LIKE ELITE.
>> AND "COBRA KAI." "LOVE IS
BLIND."
>> "BRIDGERTON."
>> AND WE'LL BE INTRODUCING
ALL-NEW CASTS OF SHOWS AND
FILMS YOU HAVEN'T SEEN YET.
>> LIKE "3 BODY PROBLEM."
>> "REBEL MOON."
>> "ONE PIECE."
>> "ALL THE LIGHT WE CANNOT
SEE."
>> AND "THEY CLONED TYRONE."
>> AND SPEAKING OF, THIS NIGHT
IS ABOUT TO GET WILD. FROM A
LIVE CONVERSATION WITH THE CAST
OF "AVATAR THE LAST AIR
BENDER."
>> AND, TO LIVE APPEARANCES
FROM SOME OF YOUR FAVORITE ON
SCREEN HEROS LIKE THIS GUY
NAMED ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER.
>> HENRY CAVILL.
>> GAL GADOT. ALIA BHATT, AND
JAMIE DORNAN.
>> WE EVEN HAVE LOCAL GUESTS
FROM RIGHT HERE IN BRAZIL LIKE
SINTONIA!
>> AND THE ARCHIES CAME ALL THE
WAY FROM MUMBAI.
>> AND OF COURSE, WE WOULDN'T
BE HERE TONIGHT WITHOUT
EXCLUSIVES FROM OUR SHOWS, "DE
VOLTA AOS15".
>> "OUTER BANKS."
>> AND "NEVER HAVE I EVER."
>> WILL IS GOING TO BE SO MUCH
TO WATCH COMING YOUR WAY. SO
AFTER THE SHOW TONIGHT, BE SURE
TO ADD ALL YOUR FAVORITE MOVIES
AND SERIES TO YOUR NETFLIX
LIST.
>> AND FOR THOSE WATCHING AT
HOME, PLEASE DON'T GO ANYWHERE.
>> AND FOR ALL OF YOU HERE IN
SAO PAULO, LET'S HEAR YOU MAKE
SOME NOISE!
>> WITHOUT FURTHER ADO, TIME TO
GET YOU INTO ONE OF THE MOST
POPULAR SHOWS WORLDWIDE. "SQUID
GAME."
>> WE HAVE MAJOR NEWS ABOUT
SEASON 2 OF "SQUID GAME." WHO
IS RETURNING, WHAT FRESH FACES
WE GET IN THE ARENA THIS TIME.
>> BUT FIRST.
>> THIS GLOBAL HIT IS NOW
BECOMING A REALITY COMPETITION.
"SQUID GAME"
>> IT'S FUNNY THIS.
>> HOW ARE WE DOING? EVERYTHING
GOING GOOD? SO CAN I GET SOME
NOISE FROM MY "ELITE" FANS?
YES, WE HAVE HAD SIX SEASONS OF
SECRETS, MURDERS, AND STEAMY
SCENES. SO SEASON 7 WILL BE NO
EXCEPTION. TO LET US KNOW WHAT
WE HAVE TO LOOK FORWARD TO ARE
THE PRINCE AND PRINCESS, IVAN
AND ISADORA BETTER KNOWN AS
ANDRE LAMOGLIA AND VALENTINA
ZENERE.
>> SEASON SIX LOOKED SO
INTENSE. WHERE DOES EVERYBODY
STAND GOING INTO THIS NEW
SCHOOL YEAR?
>> YES. CHASE. WELL, ONCE
AGAIN, WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
PRETTY INTENSE THINGS GOING ON.
BUT YOU NEVER REALLY KNOW
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN
"ELITE." BUT WE CAN PROMISE WE
WILL BE A LOT OF NEW
CHARACTERS. NEW STORY. ANYTHING
YOU WILL LOVE.
>> DO WE HAVE ANY NEW FACES
SHOWING UP?
>> YEAH, CHASE. WE HAVE A LOT
OF NEW FACES.
>> CAN I HAVE SOME BIG NOISE? A
PERSON FROM BRAZIL LIKE ME.
YEAH. ACTUALLY, I GREW UP IN
RIO. ANITTA!
>> YOU ARE GOING TO LOVE EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF THEM. SO GET
READY FOR WHAT'S COMING.
>> NOW, SHOULD WE GIVE THE
PEOPLE WHAT THEY WANT?
>> YEAH. IT BROKE THE INTERNET.
>> THIS YEAR IS JUST AS EPIC.
BECAUSE WE ARE LITERALLY GOING
TO BE FALLING FROM HEAVEN. HOPE
YOU GUYS ENJOY THIS SEASON AS
MUCH AS WE DID.
>> YEAH. BUT FIRST, TAKE IT
AWAY, ANITTA.
>>> HEY! HELLO! HOW ARE WE
GOING OUT THERE? GOOD? SO, IF
YOU'RE LIKE ME, YOU ARE
THRILLED BY THE EXTENSION OF
THE "BRIDGERVERSE." NEW
FASHION? BACK STORIES? YES
PLEASE. IT IS MY GREATEST HONOR
TO PRESENT TO YOU FROM THE
BELOVED, ACCLAIMED INSTANTLY
ICONIC SHOW, "QUEEN CHARLOTTE,
A BRIDGERTON STORY,"  YOUR
QUEEN AND  KING, INDIA
AMARTEIFIO AND COREY
MYLCHREEST.
>> WOW. WOW. WOW. WOW. TUDUM!
>> IT IS SO, SO, SO, SO GREAT
TO BE HERE. AND IT'S SO
EXCITING TO SEE SO MANY OF THE
BEST FANS. YOU GUYS ARE
AMAZING!
>> ABSOLUTELY. AND WE HAVE ALL
SEEN YOUR RECREATIONS OF THE MY
HEART CALLS YOUR NAME SCENE.
>> ABSOLUTELY HILARIOUS.
>> YEP. YOU GUYS ARE BETTER
ACTORS THAN US. I THINK WE
MIGHT NOT HAVE JOBS AFTER THIS.
>> I HOPE YOU'RE WRONG. I HOPE
YOU'RE WRONG. BUT SERIOUSLY, WE
HAD SUCH A GREAT TIME FILMING
THAT SCENE. AND THE ENTIRE SHOW
IS FILLED WITH JUST THE MOST
WONDERFUL PEOPLE IN THE WORLD.
AND THE GREAT STORY FROM
SHONDA. AND OF COURSE IT WASN'T
SO BAD WORKING WITH THIS ONE.
>> AW. THANKS COREY. I WISH I
COULD SAY THE SAME THING. BUT
YOU WERE A NIGHTMARE TO WORK
WITH. NO, NO, NO! I'M JOKING!
COME BACK. HE WAS INCREDIBLE TO
WORK WITH. ALONG WITH, WE LOVE
YOU! OH, YOU GUYS! YOU GUYS! AS
I WAS SAYING.
>> WHAT WERE YOU SAYING?
>> THESE PEOPLE ARE INCREDIBLE.
AND YEAH, WE ARE SO FORTUNATE
TO BE HERE AND YEAH, CONTINUE
TO LOVE.
>> YEAH. WE WERE --
>> STOP IT!
>> WE JUST WORKED SO HARD TO
ADD OUR CHAPTER TO THE
"BRIDGERTON" STORY SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR WELCOMING IT WITH
SUCH OPEN ARMS. IT MEANS SO
MUCH THAT WE CREATED SOMETHING
NEW THAT IS SO EXCITING TO THE
FANS OF THE ORIGINAL
"BRIDGERTON" SERIES.
>> AND SPEAKINGOVER THE
ORIGINAL SERIES, WE HAVE A
SPECIAL MESSAGE FOR YOU FROM
THE INCOMPARABLE GOLDA
ROSHEUVEL!
>> CHOW CHIAO!
>> BYE!
>> THANK YOU INDIA AND COREY.
AND HELLO, TUDUM! JUST LIKE
YOU, I HAVE DELIGHTED IN
WATCHING QUEEN CHARLOTTE'S
STORY UNFOLD. I HAD SUCH FUN
MAKING THIS SHOW. FROM SHONDA
RHIME'S SCRIPT. WE CAME
TOGETHER AS A CAST AND CREW TO
CREATE SOMETHING TRULY MAGICAL.
AS YOU KNOW, ONE OF MY FAVORITE
THINGS ABOUT WORKING IN THE
BRIDGERVERSE IS THE BALLS. THE
OUTFITS, THE DANCING, THE
ROMANCE. IT'S FABULOUS. AND I
LOVE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO SHARE
THAT EXPERIENCE WITH OUR FANS
THROUGH THE IMMERSIVE QUEEN'S
BALL. HERE IS A TASTE OF THE
MAGIC.
>> HER MAJESTY THE QUEEN
REQUESTS THE HONOR OF YOUR
PRESENCE.
>> THIS IS SURE TO BE THE EVENT
OF THE SEASON.
>> AS YOU CAN SEE, WE HAVE
HOSTED THESE MAGNIFICENT EVENTS
ALL OVER THE WORLD. AND, TUDUM,
I'M PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE WE ARE
BRINGING THE EXPERIENCE TO SAO
PAULO. SO LACE UP YOUR CORSETS
AND BRING YOUR DANCING CARD. I
EXPECT TO SEE YOU THERE,
BRAZIL. AND NOW, I KNOW YOU'RE
DESPERATE TO FIND OUT WHAT'S TO
COME ON THE NEWEST SEASON OF
BRIDGERTON. SO, IT IS MY
PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE TO YOU
THE WOMAN WHO KNOWS ALL. LADY
WHISTLEDOWN HERSELF. NICOLA
COUGHLAN!
>> HELLO BRAZIL ! HELLO,
BRAZIL! OH MY GOODNESS.
HONESTLY, EVERYONE SHOULD COME
HERE BECAUSE YOU MAKE EVERYBODY
FEEL LIKE BEYONCE. THIS IS THE
BEST PLACE. SO, THIS IS MY
THIRD TUDUM. AND I'M SO EXCITED
AND SO HONORED TO BE HERE WITH
YOU LIVE IN SAO PAULO! THE
BRIDGERTON FANDOM IS ONE OF THE
MOST PASSIONATE IN THE WORLD
AND I KNOW YOU'RE DYING TO KNOW
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN
SEASON 3. SO, CAN ELOISE AND
PEN MEND THEIR FRIENDSHIP? IS
PENELOPE FINALLY DONE WITH
YELLOW DRESSES? THIS SEASON,
PENELOPE RETURNS TO LONDON
DETERMINED TO BECOME A NEW
WOMAN WITH A NEW INDEPENDENCE
AND A NEW DETERMINATION. I CAN
PROMISE YOU QUITE THE
SCANDALOUS SEASON AND WE CANNOT
WAIT TO TAKE YOU ALONG FOR THE
CARRIAGE RIDE. NOW, DEAREST
VIEWERS,  WITHOUT ANY FURTHER
ADO, IT IS FINALLY TIME FOR OUR
FIRST LOOK AT "BRIDGERTON,"
SEASON 3! OKAY. WE OPEN OUR
SEASON WITH THE RETURN FROM THE
COUNTRY SIDE AND PENELOPE GETS
HERSELF A WHOLE NEW LOOK.
COLLIN BRIDGERTON HAS RETURNED
FROM HIS TRAVELS IN FRANCE,
SPAIN, AND ITALY AND HIS NEW
LOOK IS NOT TOO BAD EITHER.
BOTH CARMEN AND PEN HAVE DONE
SOME GROWING UP AND ONLY TIME
WILL TELL HOW THEIR FRIENDSHIP
WILL DEVELOP. FOR BOOK FANS,
YOU MAY HAVE AN IDEA. BUT I CAN
PROMISE YOU ARE IN FOR A
MAGICAL AND ROMANTIC SEASON. I
LOVE YOU! WHEN THERE'S MORE TO
SHARE ABOUT IT, YOU WILL HEAR
ABOUT IT FROM LADY WHISTLEDOWN
FIRST. THANK YOU BRAZIL AND
THANK YOU SAO PAULO!
>>> HELLO, TUDUM! LILY HERE! WE
ARE GETTING READY FOR SEASON
FOUR OF "EMILY IN PARIS" AND
ARE SO EXCITED TO SEE WHAT'S
NEXT FOR EMILY. IT'S SAFE TO
SAY WE ENDED ON A DRAMATIC NOTE
LAST SEASON. AND, SURPRISE, IT
DOES NOT END THERE. SO MUCH
HAPPENED THAT WE NEEDED ANSWERS
TO. IS ALFIE STILL HEARTBROKEN?
WILL MINDY AND THE BAND GO TO
EURO VISION? WHAT ABOUT KAMI?
AND THE QUESTION ON ALL OF OUR
MINDS. WILL EMILY AND GABRIELLE
FINALLY GET TOGETHER? I WISH I
COULD TELL YOU MORE. BUT YOU'LL
JUST HAVE TO WAIT TO FIND OUT.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT WE
HAVE MORE FUN, MORE FASHION,
AND OF COURSE, MORE DRAMA IN
STORE FOR YOU. EMILY IS GOWNING
TO HAVE TO DECIDE IF EVERYTHING
SHE HAS EVER WANTED IS REALLY
WHAT SHE NEEDS. AND WHILE
EMILY'S HEART WILL ALWAYS
REMAIN TRUE TO PARIS, HER LIFE
TAKES SOME UNEXPECTED TWISTS
THIS SEASON. DON'T BE SURPRISED
TO FIND HER ON A "ROMAN
HOLIDAY."
>> NOW BACK. LOOK, THERE IS
NOTHING LIKE WATCHING A GREAT
HEIST MOVIE. WHEN THE PERFECT
PLAN COMES TOGETHER AGAINST ALL
ODDS, YOU NEED SKILL,
INGENUITY, AND AN EXPERT CREW
WHO CAN HANDLE THEMSELVES IN
ANY SITUATION. NOW, TO GIVE YOU
A SNEAK PEEK OF HIS BRAND NEW
HIGH-FLYING ACTION PACKED HEIST
MOVIE, HERE'S THE MAN WITH THE
PLAN. KEVIN HART.
>>> TUDUM! , FIRST OFF, I JUST
WANT TO SAY IT'S SO GOOD TO SEE
YOU GUYS HAVING A GOOD TIME.
GO, NETFLIX. SECOND OF ALL, I
WANT TO KNOW IF ANYONE HAS ANY
EXPERIENCE PULLING OFF A HEIST.
I'M TALKING ABOUT A MAJOR,
MAJOR HEIST. ONE, I HAVE A VERY
LUCRATIVE PROPOSITION ATTACHED
TO. IT INVOLVES 500 MILLION IN
GOLD. SO, GOING ONCE, GOING
TWICE, LOOK, IF YOU DO, THIS IS
THE TIME SO TO SPEAK UP BECAUSE
I'M TRYING TO PUT A FEW MORE
PEOPLE TOGETHER TO ADD TO MY --
HOLD ON, I HAVE ANOTHER CALL.
HOLD ON A SECOND.
>> KEVIN, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> HEY, GUGU! I'M JUST BROWSING
NETFLIX LOOKING FOR A NEW SHOW
TO BINGE.
>> I KNOW YOU ARE TALKING TO
TUDUM.
>> THAT'S ABSURD.
>> IT'S A LIVE STREAM. EVERYONE
CAN SEE YOU ARE LOOKING FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD TO THE CREW.
>> WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
CREW?
>> WHY ARE YOU SHOPPING FOR NEW
RECRUITS?
>> WE JUST NEED A FEW TOPNOTCH
PEOPLE.
>> WE DON'T NEED ANYBODY. OUR
TEAM IS SOLID. WE HAVE A PILOT.
, A SAFE CRACKER.
>> WE CAN DO THIS. TRY CAN ME.
>> THERE IS NO ONE ELSE.
>> A TECH WIZARD. WE CAN BLOCK
THE PLANE'S SIGNAL BUT IT LOOKS
LIKE A BOMB.
>> IT REALLY DOES.
>> AN EXTRACTION EXPERT.
>> NEAR THE DROP SITE NOW.
>> A MASTER OF DISGUISE.
>> TOO MUCH?
>> ARE YOU GOING FOR GANDALF
THE GRAY?
>> AND A MASTER MIND. THAT'S
YOU KEVIN.
>> MASTER MIND? I DON'T KNOW IF
I WOULD CALL MYSELF MASTER
MIND. BUT IF YOU INSIST, I'LL
JUST GO WITH THAT. THAT'S FINE.
>> SO YOU'RE GOOD THEN.
>> WE'RE GOOD.
>> AND WE SHOULDN'T SHOW ANY
MORE CLIPS. IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
A SECRET HEIST. RIGHT?
>> COME ON, WE CAN SHOW THEM A
LITTLE MORE.
>> I LOVE EVERY SECOND OF THIS.
>> I CAN'T WAIT FOR YOU GUYS TO
MEET THE WHOLE CREW, LIFT IS
COMING TO NETFLIX JANUARY,
2024.
>> HELLO!
>> HEY, I'M VANESSA LACHEY.
>> AND I'M NICK LACHEY.
>> WE HAVE FOUND COUPLES FIND
LOVE IN THE POTS.
>> WHAT'S INCREDIBLE IS THAT
THIS LOVE EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN
WORKING ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
>> COUPLES FROM JAPAN AND
BRAZIL FOUND LOVE IN THIS
EXPERIMENT, GOT MARRIED AND ARE
STILL TOGETHER.
>> NEXT UP, "LOVE IS BLIND" IS
HEADED TO SWEDEN AND THE UNITED
KINGDOM.
>> BUT FOR YOU, WE ARE EXCITED
TO GIVE YOU A SNEAK PEEK AT
SOME OF THE HOPEFUL SINGLES WHO
WILL ONCE AGAIN TEST IF LOVE IS
TRULY BLIND.
>> HERE IS YOUR FIRST LOOK AT
"LOVE IS BLIND," SEASON 5.
>>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> I'M GOOD.
>> I LOVE YOUR VOICE ALREADY.
>> SO WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING FOR
IN A PARTNER?
>> INTELLIGENCE, DEPENDABILITY.
I'LL BE HONEST WITH YOU. I HAVE
A TRACK RECORD OF CRAPPY
RELATIONSHIPS AND I JUST
HAVEN'T FOUND THE RIGHT PERSON.
>> DOESN'T FREAK ME OUT.
DOESN'T SCARE ME AT ALL.
>> HAVE YOU BEEN IN LONG-TERM
RELATIONSHIPS?
>> I WAS ACTUALLY ENGAGED.
>> I HAVEN'T TOLD ANYONE ELSE
THIS BUT I HAVE BEEN MARRIED
ONCE BEFORE.
>> IF ME AND YOU CAN
POTENTIALLY GET MARRIED, YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO HOLD ANYTHING BACK
FROM ME AND I'M NOT GOING TO
HOLD ANYTHING BACK FROM YOU.
>> I LOVE YOU. MY MOM SAYS
LIKE, MAYBE YOU'RE NOT MEANT TO
BE IN A RELATIONSHIP. YEAH. I'M
DEFINITELY NOT A PERFECT
PERSON. BUT I KNOW I DESERVE
LOVE.
>>> SO WE ARE HALFWAY THROUGH
THE NEW SEASON OF LOVE IS BLIND
BRAZIL AND THE HOSTS KLEBBER
TOLEDO AN MY COSTAR CAMILLA ARE
BRINGING YOU ALL THE SPICE THIS
SEASON. WE HAVE A CONTROVERSIAL
CAST MATE WHO THINKS HE IS ALL
THAT AND A COUPLE WHO SHARE IT
IS SAME NAME AND A COUPLE WHO
LOOKS EXACTLY ALIKE. YOU GUYS
KNOW WHO I'M TALKING ABOUT?
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO PREDICT WHO
IS SAYING YES AND WHO IS SAYING
NO. AND IF THIS SEASON ISN'T
ALREADY FULL OF SURPRISES, THE
LOVE IS BLIND BRAZIL SEASON 3
REUNION WILL BE LIVE ON JULY
2nd. UH-HUH. THAT'S RIGHT.
COMPLETELY UNPREDICTABLE ON
NETFLIX. SO STAY TUNED FOR MORE
DETAILS AFTER THE SHOW. BUT
FIRST. HERE IS A SNEAK PEEK AT
THE REST OF THE SEASON ON LOVE
IS BLIND, BRAZIL.
>>> THE ESSEX QUEEN IS BACK AND
FOR SOMETHING HOT AND HUGE, NO.
NOT THAT YOU DIRTY LITTLE
WANKERS. THIS IS THE TOO HOT TO
HANDLE MOBILE GAME AND IT IS
BECOMING HOTTER THAN EVER. I'LL
BE THERE TO GIVE YOU THE ADVICE
WHEN EVER THE DRAMA GETS TOO
DRAMATIC. GUYS, HOW IS THIS
GOING TO WORK? AM I GOING TO BE
IN THE GAME? OH MY GOD!
>> I LOOK LIKE A SEXY LITTLE
THING DON'T I? THINGS ARE ABOUT
TO HEAT UP THIS SUMMER. JUST
DON'T TELL LANA. SHHHH.
>> SCHOOL IS BACK IN SESSION!
THAT'S RIGHT, TUDUM! "DE VOLTA
AOS15" IS COMING BACK TO
NETFLIX FOR ANOTHER WILD SEASON
ON JULY 6. BUT THIS TIME, ANITA
IS NOT ALONE. WE FOUND OUT AT
THE END OF SEASON 1, THAT JOEL
FIGURED OUT THE SECRET TO TIME
TRAVEL. IF YOU THOUGHT ONE TIME
TRAVELER COULD THROW THE PAST
OFF, IMAGINE HOW MUCH TROUBLE
TWO COULD GET INTO. SO PLAN TO
JOURNEY BACK INTO THE MID 2000s
FOR MORE NOSTALGIA, MORE
CRUSHES, AND A LOT OF FUN. AND
UP NEXT IS SOMETHING I'M VERY
EXCITED ABOUT. "COBRA KAI" IS
GEARING UP FOR A NEW SEASON.
AND WE ARE GOING TO GET A
GLIMPSE BEHIND THE SCENES. BUT
FIRST, I WANT TO LEAVE YOU GUYS
WITH A LITTLE TREAT. A SNEAK
PEEK AT THE NEW SEASON OF "DE
VOLTA AOS15" AND GOOD NEWS. YOU
DON'T NEED A VHS PLAYER TO
WATCH IT. CHECK IT OUT!
>>> HELLO TUDUM. OI, BRAZIL!
>> IT'S RALPH MACCHIO HERE WITH
WILLIAM ZABKA, YOUR FAVORITE
VALLEY SENSEIS.
>> WE WOULDN'T BE HERE WITHOUT
THE SUPPORT OF ALL YOU DIE-HARD
FANS.
>> WILLIAM HERE IS GETTING
PRETTY NOSTALGIC. HE HAS
ALREADY SHED A TEAR OR TWO.
>> I DON'T CRY. YOU'RE THE
CRIER.
>> YES, IT'S TRUE. I CAN'T HELP
IT. IT'S AMAZING HOW FAR WE
HAVE COME FROM THE ICONIC 80s
KARATE MOVIE TO SIX SEASONS OF
A NETFLIX SERIES. SO WE GOT THE
CAST TOGETHER TO GIVE TUDUM A
LITTLE SOMETHING EXTRA.
>> LET'S GO. ROLL THE TAPE!
>> WHERE HAVE YOU BEEN?
>> OH HI.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> HEY!
>> SO AWESOME.
>> A GROWN WOMAN HIDING UNDER A
TABLE TO SCARE A YOUNG BOY.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> MY BONES HURT FROM TRAINING
ALREADY.
>> HEY!
>> THIS WAS BEFORE JACOB WAS 20
MINUTES LATE.
>> IS HE ON HIS WAY?
>> HEY MAN, DO YOU KNOW WHAT
TIME THE TABLE READ IS
TOMORROW?
>> I'M GLAD YOU COULD MAKE IT.
YOU HAVE SOME EXPLAINING TO DO.
>> GREAT TO HAVE EVERYBODY
BACK. SO EXCITED TO BE HERE.
>> YOU ARE REALLY AGGRESSIVE.
>> PERFECT.
>> AWESOME LONG JOURNEY, BUT IT
IS NOT OVER YET. SEASON SIX
COULD BE THE BIGGEST, BADASSEST
MOST AMAZING SEASON OF "COBRA
KAI" YET. SO ARE Y'ALL READY?
>> YES, SENSEI.
>> VICTORIOUS DOJOS ARE
IMMORTALIZED AND FOR INDIVIDUAL
COMPETITORS, THE SKY'S THE
LIMIT, BUT BEFORE WE PUT OUR
HATS INTO THE MAP, THERE IS ONE
THING WE NEED TO DO. DECIDE OUR
DOJO NAME.
>> TUDUM!
>>> OI, BRAZIL!
>> I'M BACK! AND THIS TIME,
WITH MY DECENT "NEVER HAVE I
EVER" COSTARS, JAREN LEWISON
AND DARREN BARNET.
>> WHAT'S UP BRAZIL!
>> IT'S INCREDIBLE TO BE HERE
WITH YOU GUYS TO CELEBRATE THE
FINAL SEASON OF OUR SHOW.
>> TRULY THE END OF AN ICONIC
ERA.
>> ICONIC IS ALMOST AN
UNDERSTATEMENT. I MEAN, I
REMEMBER THAT ONE TIME, WE HAD
A FULL ON CONVERSATION WITH THE
COYOTE.
>> YEAH. THAT DID HAPPEN.
>> AND I REMEMBER WHEN SHE
DEMOLISHED EVERYONE AT MODEL
UN.
>> BECAUSE SHE IS A FREAKING
GENIUS.
>> AND YOU WHAT SHE GAVE AWAY?
HER ONE FREE BOINK CARD.
>> SHE DID, COME ON.
>> THERE HAVE BEEN SO MANY
GREAT MOMENTS IN THE SHOW, SO I
WANT TO ASK BOTH OF YOU WHAT
YOUR FAVORITE MOMENTS WERE.
>> FAVORITE MOMENT? I MEAN,
THERE HAVE BEEN SO MANY AMAZING
MOMENTS ONSET. BUT MOMENTS LIKE
THIS WITH THE FANS. NEVER GETS
OLD. I THINK, UNREAL. I WILL
GET SAPPY. MY SARCASTIC SELF
WILL GET SAPPY FOR A SECOND. I
WILL NEVER FORGET MEETING YOU
AND MEETING YOU ON THE FIRST
DAY OF WORK.
>> AW.
>> A PRETTY GREAT MOMENT.
>> WHAT ABOUT YOU?
>> MAN, IT IS TOO HARD TO
CHOOSE. YOU ARE TWO OF THE
GREATEST GIFTS I HAVE RECEIVED
IN MY LIFE. KNOWING YOU, I HAVE
LEARNED FROM YOU, YOU INSPIRE
ME. BUT IF I'M GOING TO BE
REAL, GETTING HIT BY A CAR WAS
PRETTY FUN!
>> THAT WAS SO AWESOME.
>> THAT WAS PRETTY GOOD.
>> EVERY TIME I HEAR FROM FANS,
THEY ARE ALWAYS SAYING THEY
FEEL SO SEEN IN THIS SHOW. WHY
DO YOU GUYS THINK YOUR
CHARACTERS HAVE BEEN SO
RELATABLE? MAITREYI?
>> NO, JAREN.
>> I THINK THE REASON IT IS SO
POPULAR IS BECAUSE OF THE
WRITING. THE CHARACTERS,
WHETHER IT'S DAVEY, PAXTON.
THERE  IS SO MUCH IN "NEVER
HAVE I EVER" THAT YOU CAN
RELATE TO. YOU CAN LOVE, CRY,
LAUGH. IT'S BEEN TRULY AN
HONOR.
>> I KNOW SO MANY PEOPLE RELATE
TO GOOD OLD DAVEY. ALL OF HER
MESSUPS. ALL OF HER GREAT WINS.
I THINK EVERY CHARACTER IN THE
SHOW IS JUST SO HUMAN. AND,
TRULY, WE CAN ALSO SEE
OURSELVES IN ALL OF THOSE
CHARACTERS. AND THAT'S AMAZING.
YOU  HEAR THAT? THEY ARE SAYING
DEVI. TEAM DEVI. ANYWAY, EACH
OF OUR CHARACTERS SEEM TO COME
KIND OF FULL CIRCLE FROM SEASON
1 TO 4. WHAT DO YOU GUYS FEEL
IS YOUR BIGGEST CHARACTER
MOMENT THROUGHOUT THE SHOW?
>> ALL RIGHT, LET'S JUST TALK
ABOUT CLIMBING THROUGH THE
WINDOW AND KISSING IN THE RAIN.
>> THAT'S THE BIGGEST MOMENT?
>> THAT'S NOT THE BIGGEST
MOMENT, BUT A MEMORABLE MOMENT.
PAXTON, I THINK YOU KNOW,
REALIZING HE WANTS TO GO BACK
TO SCHOOL, FIND HIMSELF, BECOME
A TEACHER, HE IS GROWING INTO
HIMSELF. FINDING WHAT HE LOVES
AND I HOPE EVERYONE CAN DO
THAT.
>> VERY TRUE.
>> I THINK BEN HAS GONE THROUGH
A LOT. HE WENT FROM BEING RUDE,
OBNOXIOUS TO CONFESSING HIS
LOVE TO DEVI IN THE END. HE
STARTED OUT TEASING HER, NOW
THEY'RE IN LOVE. A PRETTY BIG
JOURNEY I THINK. NOW, I DO WANT
TO SAY DEVI IS THE QUEEN OF
SELF-IMPROVEMENT. SELF-LOVE.
GIVE IT UP FOR SELF-LOVE. SO,
DAVE, I WANT TO ASK YOU, WHAT
WAS YOUR FAVORITE STAND-OUT
MOMENT PLAYING DEVI?
>> WELL, I MEAN, OKAY. HOW CAN
YOU PICK ONE MOMENT? THERE ARE
SO MANY STAND-OUT MOMENTS FOR
DEVI. THAT'S WHY SO MANY OF US
AROUND THE WORLD CAN RELATE TO
THIS YOUNG BROWN GIRL THAT JUST
HAS THE WHOLE REST OF HER LIFE
AHEAD OF HER. SO I THINK HER
WHOLE JOURNEY HAS BEEN A
STAND-OUT MOMENT. TRULY. SO
YEAH. OKAY. ONE MORE. ONE LAST
QUESTION.
>> ONE MORE.
>> WHAT ARE YOU GUYS GOING TO
MISS MOST ABOUT MAKING THE SHOW
AND WHY IS IT EVERY BREATHING
MOMENT YOU GUYS ARE BESIDE ME
EVERY TIME I'M AROUND YOU,
EVERY TIME YOU GUYS GET TO LOOK
AT ME, EVERY TIME YOU ARE IN A
SCENE WITH ME, EVERY TIME YOU
JUST GET TO TALK TO ME.
>> I FEEL LIKE THAT'S ENOUGH.
>> WE'RE GETTING OFF TOPIC
HERE.
>> JUST WANT TO PUT THAT OUT
THERE.
>> I THINK I'M GOING TO MISS
HANGING OUT WITH YOU GUYS FIRST
OFF. I KNOW IT IS CHEESY, BUT
WE REALLY HAVE BECOME A FAMILY
AND CREATING "NEVER HAVE I
EVER" CHANGED MY ENTIRE LIFE.
IT MADE SOME OF MY BEST FRIENDS
AND PEOPLE THAT WILL BE WITH ME
FOREVER. AND IT IS REALLY HARD
TO SAY GOOD-BYE TO SEEING EACH
OTHER EVERY DAY. BUT WE'LL BE
AROUND.
>> GUYS, I WANT YOU TO KNOW, I
WANT YOU TO KNOW, HEY. WOO! I
WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT WE ARE
ACTUALLY FRIENDS IN REAL LIFE.
LIKE, WE SPEND TIME. WE HANG
OUT. IT'S REAL. LOVE IS REAL.
LIKE I SAID, I HAVE LEARNED SO
MUCH FROM BOTH OF YOU. YOU GUYS
ARE SO HIGHLY INTELLECTUAL, SO
TALENTED AT WHAT YOU DO. AND I
LOVE YOU WITH ALL OF MY HEART.
>> I LOVE YOU, TOO.
>> I LOVE YOU BRO.
>> I LOVE YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT. TO EVERYONE HERE
WITH US IN BRAZIL, AND THOSE AT
HOME WATCHING ON THE LIVE
STREAM, THANK YOU.
>> HEY. GUYS, THIS SHOW HAS
MEANT THE ABSOLUTE WORLD TO US.
AND YOU DID THAT FOR US.
>> AND TO KNOW IT HAD AN IMPACT
ON ALL OF YOU, I MEAN, IT IS
SERIOUSLY MORE THAN WE COULD
HAVE EVER, EVER ASKED FOR.
>> SO. FOR THE LAST TIME, HERE
IS A FINAL FAREWELL FROM THE
CAST OF "NEVER HAVE I EVER ! "
>> GOOD-BYE! FOR NOW.
>> NOW THIS IS OUR LAST NIGHT
TOGETHER SO WE NEED TO GRAB
THIS PARTY BY THE BALLS AND
SQUEEZE EVERY LAST DROP OF FUN
OUT OF IT. I HEAR IT. IT WAS AN
UNSUCCESSFUL MONTH FOR YOU.
>> HEY GUYS. IT'S DEVI
VISHWAKUMAR. YOUR FAVORITE
HINDU GIRL OF THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY.
>> TYRA BANKS WASN'T CONSIDERED
HOT IN HIGH SCHOOL EITHER.
>> HERE I COME.
>> I FEEL LIKE I'LL GET COLD.
>> YOU SHOULD BEGIN AND OFTEN.
AND BY SOMEONE WHO KNOWS HOW.
>> I REALLY, REALLY LIKE A
BOYFRIEND.
>> LET'S GO THROUGH THE BEST
THREE-PERSON RAGER THIS PARTY
HAS EVER SEEN.
>> AND NOT SOME NERD FROM ONE
OF MY AP CLASSES. I JUST WANTED
TO BE A STONE COLD HOTTIE WHO
COULD ROCK ME ALL NIGHT LONG.
THIS MORNING I REALLY JUST WANT
TO SAY, THANK YOU. I FEEL
REALLY GRATEFUL. I HAVE THIS
AWESOME LIFE FULL OF DOPE
PEOPLE WHO CARE ABOUT ME AND
WHO LOVE ME. ANYWAY, I LOVE YOU
GUYS.
>> ALSO, WOULDN'T BE MAD IF YOU
EQUALLY DISTRIBUTED MY FRESHMAN
15 BETWEEN MY BOOBS AND MY ASS.
>> LONG TIME NO SEE, RIGHT?
OKAY GUYS. WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
NEVER HAVE I EVER BEEN SO
PUMPED AND WANTED TO TIME
TRAVEL TO THE 60s , POP SOME
BURGERS AND SHAKES AFTER
WATCHING A TEASER BUT SINCE YOU
AND I CAN'T GO TO RIVERDALE, I
HAVEN SITED OUR FRIENDS OVER.
SO PLEASE HELP ME WELCOME ALL
THE WAY FROM INDIA, THE
ARCHIES!
>> GIVE IT UP, REAL LOUD GUYS.
BECAUSE WE LOVE SOUTH ASIAN
EXCELLENCE. THE ARCHIES!
>> ♪ THIS IS MY STORY SO KNOW,
YOU GOT TO KNOW ME, SO KNOW.
ALL MY IMPOSSIBLE DREAMS. ARE
RIGHT BEFORE ME, YOU KNOW. ♪
YOU SAY I'M YOUNG AND I'VE GOT
NOWHERE TO BE. I SAY THERE'S SO
MUCH I CAN DO. ♪ TRADING MY
SHOES IN. I'M ROCKING AND
ROLLING PAST YOU. SO GO.
>> THANK YOU FOR ALL THE LOVE,
BRAZIL! AND EVERYONE WATCHING
ONLINE! WE WILL SEE YOU VERY
SOON, ONLY ON NETFLIX!
>>> HEY, I'M COREY CORINNA
BROWN.
>> AND I'M KIZZY EDGELL.
>> FOR YOU LUCKY LOT.
>> AND THOSE STREAMING AT HOME,
WE HAVE AN EXCLUSIVE LOOK AT
THE OPENING OF EPISODE ONE.
>> BUT THAT'S NOT ALL. STICK
AROUND, BECAUSE FOR THE FIRST
TIME, WE ARE ALSO REVEALING THE
NAMES FOR ALL EIGHT EPISODES.
>> ENJOY! AND DON'T FORGET,
"HEARTSTOPPER" IS BACK ON
AUGUST 3, ONLY ON NETFLIX.
>> HI.
>>> HEY AGAIN, IT'S ME. OKAY.
BASED ON THE PULITZER
PRIZE-WINNING NOVEL "ALL THE
LIGHT WE CANNOT SEE" IS A
LIMITED SERIES SET DURING WORLD
WAR II THAT WILL PREMIER ON
NETFLIX NOVEMBER 2nd. HERE TO
TELL US MORE ARE ARIA MIA
LOBERTI AND LOUIS HOFMANN.
>> HELLO!
>> ARE YOU ALL HAVING A GREAT
TIME? I THINK WE ARE.
>> YEAH, WE ARE.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING US!
>> WHAT AN HONOR TO BE HERE.
AND BE WELCOME BY ALL OF YOU IN
BRAZIL. CRAZY .
>> OUR UPCOMING LIMITED SERIES
"ALL THE LIGHT WE CANNOT SEE"
HAS BEEN A LABOR OF LOVE FROM
THE VERY MOMENT WE STARTED
WORKING ON IT AND WE ARE SO,
SO, SO EXCITED TO SHARE WITH
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU .
>> WE LOVE YOU, WE LOVE YOU, WE
LOVE YOU!
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH!
>> THANK YOU.
>> TELL THEM ABOUT IT! TELL
THEM ABOUT IT!
>> OKAY, SO, THE SERIES FOLLOWS
MARIE-LAURE AND WERNER. TWO
CHARACTERS ON OPPOSITE SIDES OF
A CATASTROPHIC CONFLICT WHO
SHARE A SECRET CONNECTION THAT
WILL BECOME A BEACON OF HOPE IN
THE DARKEST OF TIMES.
>> AND WHEN I FIRST READ THE
BOOK, PROBABLY LIKE 2015, 2016,
A COUPLE OF YEARS AFTER IT CAME
OUT, I INSTANTLY CONNECTED TO
THE CHARACTER OF MARIE-LAURE TO
WE ARE REALLY DIFFERENT. I'M
SHAKING! AND, SO, I'M A FAN
FIRST. I WOULD BE RIGHT THERE
WITH ALL OF YOU OR AT HOME
WATCHING. AND, IT WAS MY VERY
FIRST ROLE, MY VERY FIRST
AUDITION. MY FIRST TIME ACTING.
SO TO BE HERE WITH YOU GUYS ON
A PROJECT I LOVE, THANK YOU!
THANK YOU! I'M PINCHING MYSELF!
>> SO, FILMING THIS SERIES HAS
ACTUALLY BEEN LIKE NO OTHER
EXPERIENCE. IT WAS EXCEPTIONAL,
EXTRAORDINARY FROM THE
LOCATIONS TO THE SETS AND TO
THE AWE-INSPIRING PERFORMANCES
OF MARK RUFFALO AND HUGH LAURIE
AND WE WERE SO THRILLED TO WORK
WITH BOTH OF THEM. AND WE ALSO
HAD A LOT OF FUN TORMENTING
THEM ONSET. MAKING FUN OF THEM.
MAKING JOKES ABOUT THEM.
>> IMITATING THEM.
>> THEY LOVED IT.
>> I THINK. I'M PRETTY SURE.
>> I THINK SO.
>> AND SO. WE DO HAVE
SOMETHING VERY, VERY SPECIAL
FOR ALL OF YOU. THANK YOU FOR
BEING SUCH WONDERFUL HOSTS.
AND, WITHOUT.
>> THANK YOU SO, SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY, VERY MUCH.
>> WITHOUT FURTHER ADO, WITHOUT
FURTHER ADO, PLEASE LET US
PRESENT TO YOU A VERY SPECIAL
LOOK AT "ALL THE LIGHT WE
CANNOT SEE"!
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH!
>> THERE WAS THIS VOICE I
LISTENED TO ON THE RADIO. AND I
WILL NEVER KNOW WHO SHE  IS.
>> WHATEVER IN THE WORLD YOU
ARE.
>> I PRAY THAT THE SIGNAL FROM
THIS RADIO IS REACHING YOU. IF
YOU CAN HEAR  ME, REMEMBER.
DARKNESS LASTS NOT EVEN FOR ONE
SECOND. WHEN YOU TURN ON THE
LIGHT.
>>> WOO! ALL RIGHT, SO NEXT UP,
WE HAVE A SNEAK PEEK OF THE
HIGHLY ANTICIPATED NEW SERIES
FROM THE CREATORS OF GAME OF
THRONES, "3 BODY PROBLEM." HERE
TO KICK OFF WHAT YOU ARE GOING
TO BE SEEING, WELCOME JESS HONG
AND BENEDICT WONG!
>> HELLO EVERYONE! HELLO
EVERYONE WATCHING AT HOME!
THANK YOU FOR TUNING IN.
>> NOW, WHAT IF WE KNEW THERE
WAS AN OUTSIDE FORCE
MANIPULATING EVENTS ON EARTH?
WHAT WOULD IT DO TO THE FABRIC
OF OUR SOCIETY? HOW WOULD YOU
REACT?
>> INSPIRED BY THE, HI!
INSPIRED BY THE INTERNATIONALLY
CELEBRATED BOOK TRILOGY, "3
BODY PROBLEM" CHRONICLES
HUMANITY'S RESPONSE TO ITS
GRAVEST THREAT.
>> IT'S A THRILLING AND EPIC
STORY ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
REALITY ON EARTH STARTS TO
BREAK DOWN.
>> OH YEAH. A STORY ABOUT HUMAN
CONNECTION. INVESTIGATIVE
MYSTERIES. EARTH-SHATTERING
DISCOVERIES. AND MUCH, MUCH
MORE.
>> WE ARE SO HONORED TO PRESENT
THIS VERY FIRST LOOK AT A SHOW
WE HAVE WORKED SO HARD ON.
>> SO VERY HARD.
>> WITHOUT FURTHER ADO, THIS IS
"3 BODY PROBLEM."
>> AS CHILDREN, WE FEAR THE
DARK.
>> ANYTHING MIGHT BE OUT THERE.
THE UNKNOWN TROUBLES US. THERE
ARE THOSE WHO SAY WE SHOULD NOT
INQUIRE TOO CLOSELY, INTO WHO
ELSE MIGHT BE LIVING IN THAT
DARKNESS. BETTER, NOT TO KNOW.
>> BUT WE CONTINUE TO SEARCH.
LIFE LOOKS FOR LIFE.
>> WOW, THAT WAS EPIC! ALL
RIGHT, SO LET'S GIVE IT UP FOR
THE SERIES STARS BENEDICT WONG,
JESS HONG, JOVAN ADEPO, ALEX
SHARP, AND JOHN BOYEGA.  JOHN
BRADLEY. JOHN BRADLEY.
>> THAT WAS SO COOL.
>> RIGHT?
>> WHAT DO YOU GUYS THINK OF
THE TEASER?
>> BRAZIL!
THAT WAS THE FIRST TIME I SAW
THAT AND MY MIND IS TOTALLY
BLOWN. UNBELIEVABLE.
>> IT'S CRAZY, THEY REALLY
PLAYED INTO ALL THE MYSTERIES
OF THE SERIES. THERE ARE SO
MANY CLUES IN THAT SHORT
SEQUENCE.
>> FOR REAL.
>> I THINK LIKE A GREAT TRAILER
SHOULD.
>> JOHN BRADLEY!
>> ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OH, THAT WAS SO SWEET.
SO, AS I WAS SAYING, IT'S LIKE
A GOOD TRAILER. IT ASKS MORE
QUESTIONS THAN IT ANSWERS. AND
HOPEFULLY, SO IT GETS PEOPLE
THINKING. AND BELIEVE IT OR
NOT, THAT WAS JUST A TINY
LITTLE PART OF WHAT OUR SHOW IS
ABOUT, BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
>> SO WHAT WAS IT LIKE TO
COLLABORATE WITH EXECUTIVE
PRODUCERS? THIS IS A GAME OF
THRONES REUNION FOR YOU.
>> IT WAS A LITTLE GAME OF
THRONES REUNION. YEAH. AND
"GAME OF THRONES." HEARD OF
"GAME OF THRONES"?
>> I THINK THEY REMEMBER, YEAH.
MAYBE.
>> THAT WAS A GREAT EXPERIENCE.
IT WAS TEN YEARS OF MY LIFE.
BUT WORKING WITH THEM AGAIN
THIS TIME WAS EVEN MORE
INCREDIBLE THIS TIME AROUND.
>> DAVID, DAN, AND ALEX MADE A
UNIQUE SHOW. THEY HAD A REALLY
UNIQUE VISION. THIS IS AN
HONOR. I WAS BLOWN AWAY WHEN I
FIRST SAW IT, WHEN I FIRST READ
IT AS I'M SURE YOU GUYS WERE.
IT IS AN HONOR TO BE A PART OF
THIS AMAZING THING THEY BROUGHT
TO LIFE.
>> AND SO, WHAT CAN YOU TELL US
ABOUT YOUR CHARACTERS?
>> OH, WELL, OKAY. SO WE PLAY,
US FOUR, WE PLAY A GROUP OF
BRILLIANT SCIENTISTS WHO ARE
RACING AGAINST TIME TO UNRAVEL
AN OTHER WORLDLY MYSTERY BEFORE
POTENTIALLY CATASTROPHIC
CONSEQUENCES.
>> I'M PLAYING AN INTELLIGENCE
OFFICER. YEP, YOU HEARD IT. I'M
INVESTIGATING THE IMPLICATIONS
OF WHAT THESE SCIENTISTS ARE
AFTER.
>> OKAY, IN THE WORLD OF THIS
SHOW, PEOPLE OBSESSIVELY PLAY A
CERTAIN VR GAME. WHAT IS THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS GAME?
>> THAT'S A REALLY GREAT
QUESTION, BUT I'M AFRAID YOU'LL
HAVE TO WAIT A LITTLE LONGER
FOR THE DETAILS ON THE VR GAME.
BUT WHAT I CAN SAY IS THE SCOPE
AND SCALE OF THE GAME IN OUR
SHOW IS INNOVATIVE IN A WAY I
HAVE NEVER EVER SEEN BEFORE.
>> SO I HAVE ONE FINAL QUESTION
FOR YOU GUYS. WHAT ARE YOU MOST
EXCITED FOR THESE LOVELY PEOPLE
TO SEE IN THE SERIES?
>> OH, MOST EXCITED?
>> I'M EXCITED FOR BRAZIL TO
SEE IT. I'M EXCITED FOR THE
WORLD TO SEE IT. I THINK THEY
HAVE MADE SOMETHING LIKE
NOTHING YOU HAVE EVER SEEN
BEFORE.
>> YEAH. FOR REAL. YOU GUYS,
IT'S A WILD RIDE YOU WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO STOP THINKING OR
TALKING ABOUT. BELIEVE  ME.
>> WOW. THAT SOUNDS EPIC.
EVERYBODY, PLEASE MAKE SURE TO
WATCH "3 BODY PROBLEM" WHEN IT
DEBUTS JANUARY, 2024, THANKS
FOR JOINING US AT TUDUM!
>>> OI, BRAZIL!
>> GUYS, IT'S SUCH AN HONOR TO
BE HERE WITH ALL OF YOU IN
PERSON AND VIRTUALLY FOR THOSE
OF YOU WATCHING AROUND THE
WORLD.
>> AFTER TWO INCREDIBLE SEASONS
OF "THE WITCHER," WE ARE
EXCITED TO FINALLY SHARE SEASON
3 WITH YOU THIS SUMMER! THANK
YOU ALL FOR JOINING US! THANK
YOU ALL FOR JOINING US IN
BRAZIL TO TALK ABOUT SEASON 3
OF "THE WITCHER."
>> WOW! GERALT, YENNEFER,
CIRI, AND JASKIER ARE FINALLY
REUNITED THIS SEASON AND I'M SO
EXCITED FOR THE FANS TO SEE
WHAT'S IN STORE FROM THE
BELTANE FESTIVAL, AN UNMISSILE
FIGHT AT SHAERRAWEDD, TO CIRI
AND GERALT FIGHTING AN AECHNA
MONSTER. WE WILL HAVE MORE
MONSTER ACTION AND WE WILL TELL
YOU ABOUT MORE, FREYA, TELL US
ABOUT YOUR HIGHLIGHTS SHOOTING
SEASON THREE.
>> WE HAVE COVERED ALL THE
SEASONS THROUGH THE SHOOT FROM
THE SNOWY MOUNTAINS OF SLOVENIA
TO MOROCCO TO THE SHORES OF
WALES. IT WAS PRETTY COOL TO
SHOOT IN SUCH EXTRAORDINARY
LOCATIONS. I WOULD SAY ONE OF
THE BIGGEST HIGHLIGHTS FOR ME,
THOUGH, WAS THE ACTION SCENES
AND GETTING TO BE A WITCHER
THOUGH TECHNICALLY, CIRI IS NOT
ACTUALLY A WITCHER. I
ABSOLUTELY LOVED ALL OF MY
FIGHT SCENES, ESPECIALLY ON THE
FERRY BOAT. OH, SORRY, WHAT
NEWS DO YOU HAVE FOR OUR
WONDERFUL TUDUM AUDIENCE, JOEY?
>> WE LOVE YOU! SO MUCH. THERE
IS SO MUCH TO TELL YOU. WE CAN
TELL YOU THE STAKES ARE HIGHER
THAN EVER THIS SEASON.
>> WE LOVE YOU, WE LOVE YOU,
WE LOVE YOU, WE LOVE YOU!
>> WE LOVE YOU! I CAN REVEAL
THAT I COME FACE TO FACE WITH
MY RIVAL, MY INFAMOUS RIVAL,
VALDO MARX ON A BOAT TO THANEDD
THIS SEASON. THERE IS A VERY
SHOCKING DEATH IN STORE. AND
YOU, FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE
NOT READ THE BOOKS ARE GOING TO
BE BLOWN AWAY BY THIS SEASON'S
BIG BAD! I SUPPOSE WE SHOULD
TALK TO HENRY? I MEAN,  MAYBE?
HENRY! TELL US ABOUT FILMING
YOUR FINAL SEASON WITH US,
HENRY.
>> GOODNESS ME, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, EVERYONE. THANK YOU. I
REALLY FEEL THE LOVE AND I LOVE
YOU GUYS, TOO. IT IS SO
WONDERFUL TO BE HERE. BUT I'M
GOING TO TALK ABOUT WHAT IT WAS
LIKE FILMING MY FINAL SEASON
AND I ACTUALLY WANT TO TALK
ABOUT MY COSTARS HERE. BECAUSE
ONCE AGAIN, IT WAS SUCH A
PLEASURE AND AN HONOR TO BE
WORKING WITH YOU GUYS. YOU GUYS
BRING SO MUCH NUANCE AND DETAIL
TO THESE CHARACTERS WHICH ARE
OFTEN AT RISK OF BEING
OVERSIMPLIFIED AND WHAT YOU
GUYS HAVE DONE WITH THE
CHARACTERS HAS INVOLVED WORK,
CARE, AND EFFORT. AND WORKING
WITH YOU GUYS WAS THE BIGGEST
PLEASURE. SO, I JUST WANT TO
SAY WE'RE GOING TO MISS YOU.
I'M GOING TO MISS YOU VERY
MUCH.
>> HENRY CAVILL, EVERYBODY!
>> WELL OUR TIME IS ALMOST UP.
AND WE OF COURSE CANNOT IGNORE
THAT THIS IS YOUR LAST SEASON
WITH US, HENRY. FROM US, FROM
EVERYONE HERE, APPARENTLY. WE
WANT TO THANK YOU SO, SO MUCH
FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
CONTRIBUTION TO THE WITCHER
ACROSS THREE SEASONS. WE ARE
GOING TO MISS YOU AND WE LOVE
YOU.
>> THANK YOU. THANK YOU JOEY.
THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOU HERE.
AND TO EVERYONE AT HOME AS
WELL. YOU GUYS ARE ALL AMAZING.
>> NOW, PLEASE ENJOY ONE OF THE
MANY EPIC MOMENTS FROM "THE
WITCHER ," SEASON THREE!
>>> CIRILLA OF CINTRA.
>> ALONE AT LAST. WELL, NOT
QUITE. I'VE BROUGHT MORE
FRIENDS THIS TIME.
>> LAST TIME I BEAT YOU WITH MY
WITS. IT'S TIME YOU MEET MY
MAGIC.
>> I LIKE MY ODDS.
>> I LIKE OUR ODDS BETTER.
>> THIS IS TOO EASY!
>> FUCK!
>> GO!
>> YOUR MAGE IS OUT OF HER
DEPTH.
>> THE ELVES CAME FOR CIRI.
>> THIS WAY!
>> ALL RIGHT, LISTEN UP TUDUM.
JOHN BOYEGA HERE WITH TEYONAH
PARRIS.
>> FROM "THEY CLONE TYRONE."
>> AND WE HAVE A SNEAK PEEK OF
OUR NEW MOVIE COMING UPRIGHT
NOW.
>> PREPARE YOURSELVES, WHAT YOU
ARE ABOUT TO SEE MAY NOT MAKE
ANY DAMN SENSE.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO GOVERNMENT
CONSPIRACIES, YOU NEVER KNOW
WHO IS LISTENING OR WATCHING.
>> LOOK, LOOK AT THIS.
>> UH-OH, JOHN, IS IT ME OR
DOES THIS GUY LOOK IDENTICAL TO
YOU?
>> LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING,
HE MAY LOOK IDENTICAL TO ME,
BUT HE CAN'T MATCH THIS.
>> WHY DON'T YOU TELL THEM THE
DETAILS SO WE CAN GET OUT OF
HERE.
>> "WE CLONE TYRONE" COVERS
SOME FREAKY EXPERIMENTS
HAPPENING IN A NEIGHBORHOOD.
>> CLONING, MIND CONTROL, AND
OTHER NEFARIOUS BUSINESS. YOU
NAME IT, THEY ARE DOING IT.
OKAY, WHAT'S THE NAME OF THAT
JORDAN PEELE MOVIE AGAIN? NOPE.
I GOTS TO GO.
>> WE GOT TO GO. LET'S GET OUT
OF HERE. CIAO, BRAZIL. LET'S
ROLL THE TRAILER!
>> EVERYTHING OKAY IN THERE,
BABY?
>> WHERE THE MONEY AT?
>> I'M AN ENTREPRENEUR. I WORK
IN THE SPIRIT OF THE PIMP GAME.
>> YOU KNOW YOUR GIRL OUGHT TO
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON IN THESE
STREETS.
>> THAT'S THE CAR RIGHT THERE.
>> SHIT. THEY GOT AN ELEVATOR
IN THIS BITCH.
>> SLICK.
>> COME ON.
>> DOESN'T THAT MAKE YOUR
SPIDEY SENSES TINGLE?
>> WHAT KIND OF SHIT IS THIS?
>> UH, WE GOT TO GO.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT WAS,
THAT WASN'T ME.
>> SOMEBODY IS CONDUCTING
EXPERIMENTS ON US.
>> IT'S IN THE FUCKING CHICKEN!
>> THIS SHIT IN EVERYTHING!
>> GRAPE DRINK? COME THE FUCK
ON.
>> IT'S OUR HOMELAND. WE DON'T
DO NOTHING ABOUT IT, NOBODY
WILL.
>> CHILL, JUST FUCKING CHILL.
>> SHIT!
>> OH WAIT.
>> OKAY, WE GOT TO TIME FOR
NEGATIVITY. SO GET ME SOME WET
NAPS SOMETHING. LET'S CLEAN HIM
UP.
>> YOU KEEP YOUR PIMP HAND
RAISED. AND BE WILLING TO
PROTECT THE ONES YOU LOVE BY
ENEMIES. EXCUSE ME KIND SIR, IF
YOU COULD POINT ME TO THE
ELEVATOR THAT LEADS DOWN TO THE
FREAKY LABORATORY, I'LL BE OUT
OF YOUR ATMOSPHERE.
>> LET'S GET IT MAN.
>> WE'RE ON THE SCENE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT HAS HAPPENED.
>> THIS SHIT FUCKED UP.
>> THAT IS THE PREVAILING
THEORY.
>>> BRAZIL! WHAT ARE WE DOING
TONIGHT? TUDUM, LET ME HEAR
YOU!
>> TO THE LEFT SIDE, HOW ARE WE
FEELING? HOW ARE WE FEELING? TO
THE RIGHT, HOW ARE WE DOING? TO
THE LOVELY PEOPLE IN THE
MIDDLE, HOW ARE WE? THIS IS
UNREAL. WE HAVE HEARD FROM SO
MANY ICONIC SHOW. YOU,
BRIDGERTON, LOVE IS BLIND.
SQUID GAME. BUT, HOLD ON. HOLD
ON. I THINK THIS IS WHAT YOU
GUYS HAVE ALL BEEN WAITING FOR.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT A LITTLE
SHOW CALLED OUTER BANKS?
>> WOW, WE ARE OFFICIALLY BACK
IN THE OUTER BANKS GETTING
READY TO GO BACK INTO
PRODUCTION FOR SEASON FOUR! AND
I HAVE TO BE HONEST, I DO HAVE
THE JET LAG TO PROVE IT. FUN
FACT FROM THE OUTER BANKS SET,
THOUGH IT IS SAO PAULO, NOT A
DIRECT FLIGHT. BUT THAT FLIGHT
HAD ME THINKING ABOUT HOW
INSANE SEASON THREE WAS. YOU
GUYS REMEMBER THAT LITTLE
SEASON? A LITTLE  POGUELANDIA?
POPE AND CLEO? RAFE STILL CRAZY
AS EVER. AND HOW ABOUT JJ AND
KI? YOU KNOW, I LOVE WORKING ON
THIS SHOW. THERE ARE SO MANY
INCREDIBLE PEOPLE BEHIND THE
SCENES WHO MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
BUT, MY ABSOLUTE FAVORITE THING
ABOUT "OUTER BANKS" IS YOU
GUYS. OUR FANS. HONESTLY, I'M
CONVINCED WE HAVE THE BEST FANS
OUT OF ANY SHOW IN THIS ENTIRE
PLANET. LET ME HEAR YOU. YOU
GUYS ARE SERIOUSLY THE
GREATEST. AND SO, WHILE WE ARE
STILL RAMPING UP FOR SEASON
FOUR, WE WANTED TO SAY THANK
YOU TO OUR INCREDIBLE FANS WITH
A LITTLE SNEAK PEEK OF THE
POGUES BACK IN ACTION AS WE
EMBARK ON SEASON FOUR. THANK
YOU GUYS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
LOVING THE SHOW. I LOVE YOU. I
LOVE YOU SO, SO, SO MUCH! ALL
RIGHT? HOW ABOUT WE ROLL THIS
CLIP?
>>> HOLE REHEARSAL! OI!
>> I'M DIANNA AGRON.
>> AND I'M BOBBY LUHNOW.
>> WE ARE PART OF THE CAST OF
THE NEW NETFLIX SERIES.
>> IT WAS MADE IN MEXICO AND IT
IS CALLED "THE CHOSEN ONE."
>> WHICH FOLLOWS THE STORY OF
MY CHARACTER JODIE.
>> HE DISCOVERS HE HAS SOME
VERY FAMILIAR SUPERPOWERS.
>> BUT NOTHING IS EVER WHAT IT
SEEMS.
>> AND TONIGHT FOR THE FIRST
TIME, LIVE FROM BRAZIL, WE
WANTED TO GIVE YOU A FIRST LOOK
INTO THIS EXCITING SERIES. ARE
YOU READY?
>> PEOPLE ARE ALWAYS GOING TO
BE LOOKING FOR US. JUST TRYING
TO KEEP YOU SAFE.
>> JODIE!
>> HEY! WATER! EARTH! FIRE!
AIR,  BENDING IN THE NAME OF
BOTH GOOD AND EVIL. SOUND
FAMILIAR? WELL AVATAR THE LAST
AIR BENDER IS COMING TO NETFLIX
IN A LIVE ACTION SERIES. BUT
YOU GUYS ALREADY KNEW THAT.
AANG,  KATARA, SOKKA, ZUKO, AND
EVEN APPA ARE BACK FOR A BRAND
NEW TAKE ON THE MOST LEGENDARY
STORIES OF OUR TIME FOR THE
FIRST TIME EVER. I HAVE THE
IMMENSE PRIVILEGE TO PLEASE
WELCOME THE CAST OF THE AVATAR
THE LAST AIR BENDER.
>> IAN OUSLEY. DALLAS LIU . AND
LAST, BUT CERTAINLY NOT LEAST,
GORDON CORMIER! THESE GUYS ARE
TRULY THE SWEETEST SOULS AND IT
HAS BEEN A PLEASURE TO GET TO
KNOW THESE GUYS. I CANNOT WAIT
FOR YOU GUY TO HEAR FROM THEM.
KIAWENTIIO, WITHOUT SPOILING
THINGS FOR THE FANS, WHAT ARE
YOU MOST EXCITED FOR THE FANS
TO SEE?
>> I'M REALLY EXCITED FOR FANS
TO SEE, I THINK THE BENDING AND
THE EFFECTS WILL BE REALLY
COOL. I ONLY GOT TO SEE ONE
FINISHED SCENE WITH THE EFFECTS
BUT IT WAS SO COOL AND I CAN'T
WAIT TO SEE THE WHOLE SERIES
DONE. I KNOW EVERYBODY IS
WORKING REALLY HARD TO MAKE IT
THE BEST THAT IT CAN BE.
ANOTHER PERSONAL FAVORITE OF
MINE IS EPISODE FIVE. I THINK
IT WAS MY FAVORITE WHEN I READ
IT AND AS SOON AS I READ IT, I
COULDN'T WAIT TO FILM IT. AND
JUST THE CHARACTERS GO THROUGH
A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS AND
THEY SEE THEIR SITUATION
THROUGH DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES
AND I JUST CAN'T WAIT FOR YOU
GUYS TO SEE THAT.
>> IT WILL BE GOOD. I'M SO
EXCITED FOR EPISODE FIVE.
>> IAN, THIS WAS A MASSIVE
PRODUCTION OVER MANY, MANY
MONTHS. ALMOST LIKE A YEAR,
RIGHT?
>> ALMOST A YEAR.
>> YEAH. WHAT WAS ONE OF YOUR
FAVORITE MEMORIES FROM THE
WHOLE EXPERIENCE?
>> OH MY GOSH, WE MADE SO MANY
MEMORIES TOGETHER. HONESTLY.
LIKE YOU SAID, WE WORK TOGETHER
AND LIVE TOGETHER FOR ALMOST A
YEAR. CREATING THIS AWESOME
SHOW. YEAH, I JUST LOVE THESE
GUYS. AND SOME OF THE MEMORIES
I WOULD HAVE TO SAY IS HAIRCUT
DAY WHERE WE LIKE REALLY GOT TO
TRANSFORM INTO THE CHARACTERS
FOR THE FIRST TIME. THAT DAY
WAS A LITTLE EASIER FOR SOME
THAN OTHERS. BUT ANOTHER THING
THAT WAS A HUGE MOMENT FOR ME
WAS GETTING TO HOLD AND
UNSHEATHE MY BOOMARANG FOR THE
FIRST TIME. A COOL THING FOR ME
WAS WORKING WITH ACTORS I WAS
FANS OF BEFOREHAND. LINING
DANNY PUDI FROM COMMUNITY.
HE'LL BE PLAYING THE MECHANIST.
IF I HAD TO CHOOSE ONE REALLY
QUICK, IT WOULD BE GETTING TO
MEET AND HANG OUT WITH MY
FAVORITE CHARACTER FOR THE
FIRST TIME WHICH IS APPA. AND
GETTING TO LIVE OUT MY DREAM OF
FLYING THROUGH THE SKY WITH MY
WOLF TAIL IN THE WIND.
>> LET'S BE REAL, YOU WERE
SCARED.
>> I WAS SO SCARED. I WAS VERY
SCARED. APPA HAD NO FACE.
>> AS A YOUNG ACTOR, HOW DID
YOU FIND STEPPING INTO THIS
HUGE PRODUCTION? WHAT WAS THAT
LIKE? DID YOUR FELLOW FIRE
NATION ACTORS LIKE DANIEL DAE
KIM OR PAUL SUN-HYUNG LEE GIVE
YOU ADVICE? HOW DID THAT
HAPPEN?
>> BEFORE I GET STARTED --
WHAT'S UP? OKAY. TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION, THIS IS SUCH A
BELOVED UNIVERSE. SO I WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT NOT ONLY AM I
LIVING UP TO THE EXPECTATIONS
OF OUR SUPPORTERS BUT I'M ALSO
OF MYSELF. SO I FOUND THAT
STEPPING THROUGH MY LOVE FOR
THE SERIES, PRINCE ZUZU AND HIS
PHENOMENAL HAIRCUT. BUT AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW, MOST OF ZUKO'S
JOURNEY IS ACCOMPANIED BY UNCLE
AIRO. SO I SPENT ALMOST EVERY
DAY WITH PAUL ONSET. AND BY THE
WAY, I THINK HE IS THE PERFECT
UNCLE. THERE ISN'T ANYONE WHO
COULD HAVE DONE A BETTER JOB
THAN HIM. BUT I RECEIVED ADVICE
PROBABLY ON THE DAILY ABOUT
ANYTHING THAT YOU COULD THINK
OF FROM WHAT IT MEAN TO BE A
LEADER OR HOW TO PRESENT
YOURSELF AS A PROFESSIONAL
ONSET. HE IS A REAL LIFE UNCLE
AIRO TO ME NOW. AND DANIEL DAE
KIM. HE HAS THE REAL LIFE
PRESENCE OF FIRE LORD OZAI. THE
DAY HE WALKED ONSET, HE WAS SO
INTIMIDATING, I KNEW HE WAS THE
FIRE LORD AND I THINK EVERYONE
CAN AGREE ON THAT. BUT WHAT I
RECEIVED FROM HIM WAS
VALIDATION. HE MADE ME FEEL
LIKE I BELONG TO BE WORKING
ALONGSIDE THESE AMAZING PEOPLE.
>> YOU MORE THAN DESERVE TO BE
HERE ON THE STAGE WORKING
ALONGSIDE THESE LOVELY PEOPLE.
OKAY? YOU ARE OUR PRINCE ZUKO.
PERIOD. ALL RIGHT, LAST BUT NOT
LEAST. I KNOW, RIGHT? COME ON.
WE ARE GOING TO HEAR FROM AANG
HIMSELF. HYPE IT UP. GORDON .
SOAK IT IN. YOU DESERVE IT.
GORDON, WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO BE
A PART OF THIS SUCH BELOVED
STORY? YOU ARE OUR AVATAR.
>> OKAY, WELL. THAT'S A PRETTY
BIG QUESTION. WITH THIS, I WILL
USE IT AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
OUR SHOW. SO AVATAR THE LAST
AIR BENDER LIVE ACTION. I FEEL
LIKE IT IS GOING TO BRING LIKE
EVERYTHING YOU KNOW AND LOVE
ABOUT THE ORIGINAL SERIES BACK
TO LIFE. AND HOPEFULLY, JUST
BRING A BUNCH OF NEW FANS WHO
HAVE NEVER HEARD OF THE SHOW
BEFORE INTO THIS UNIVERSE. AND
TO ME, THAT'S PRETTY  EXCITING.
I MEAN, I'M A FAN OF THE SHOW
PERSONALLY. AND I'M JUST
EXCITED FOR THIS AS YOU GUYS
ARE. SO, WITH THAT, WHO'S READY
FOR THE FIRST AT OUR
CHARACTERS? WE COULDN'T HEAR
YOU!
>> A LITTLE LOUDER GUYS. LET'S
GO.
>> YEAH. LET THEM KNOW.
>> OKAY, OKAY. I THINK THEY'RE
READY. I THINK THEY'RE READY. I
THINK WE'RE GOOD. I THINK WE'RE
GOOD. I THINK WE'RE GOOD.
>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> OKAY GUYS, NO JOKE. THAT'S
THE FIRST TIME I GOT TO SEE IT
BECAUSE I GUARANTEE YOU IF I
SAW THAT LIKE DURING REHEARSALS
I WOULD HAVE LEAKED THIS ON
TWITTER SO PLEASE TAKE ALL THE
PICTURES OF THESE LOVELY HUMAN
BEINGS AND PUT IT ON TWITTER
BECAUSE OH MY GOD, LET'S HEAR
IT ONE MORE TIME FOR THE CAST
OF "AVATAR THE LAST AIR
BENDER"!
>>> MAKE TODAY'S EVENT LAST ALL
YEAR AT TUDUM.COM. NETFLIX'S
OFFICIAL SITE FOR FANDOM. NEWS
INTERVIEWS, AND MORE. GO BEHIND
THE STREAMS AT TUDUM.COM.
>>> HEY EVERYONE, I'M JENNA
ORTEGA.
>> I'M EMMA,.
>> I'M HUNTER,.
>> I'M JOY.
>> BREATHE A WORD OF THIS TO
ANYONE AND I WILL END YOU.
>> WE WILL GO THROUGH SOME OF
THE BEST FAN THEORIES.
>> THERE ARE SEASON ONE
SPOILERS AHEAD.
>> SO TELL US EVERYTHING.
>> AFTER CRACKSTONE IS
DEFEATED, WE SEE HIS RING FALL
TO THE GROUND. DID SOMEONE PICK
IT UP? AND COULD THAT PERSON
INHERIT CRACKSTONE'S POWERS?
>> THING IS ALWAYS CRAWLING
AROUND. MAYBE HE PICKS IT UP.
>> I THINK WE SHOULD KEEP AN
EYE OUT FOR EUGENE.
>> HE MIGHT WANT TO CLAIM SOME
SORT OF VENGEANCE ON ANYONE WHO
BULLIED HIM.
>> SINCE WEDNESDAY DEFEATED THE
HYDE'S MASTER, HAS WEDNESDAY
BECOME THE NEW HYDE MASTER? WE
SEE WEDNESDAY DRIVE FAST TYLER
IN THAT MOMENT, TYLER STARTS TO
TRANSFORM INTO THE HYDE. COULD
THIS MEAN THAT WEDNESDAY HAS
SOME SORTOVER POWER OVER HIM?
>> I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
INTERESTING IF WEDNESDAY HAD A
MONSTER FOR A PET.
>> I WOW DOWN TO JENN.
WEDNESDAY WOULD PROBABLY COME
UP WITH SOMETHING HORRIBLE FOR
ME TO DO.
>> AS WE KNOW, PROFESSOR WEEMS
IS A SHAPE SHIFTER. HE GETS
STABBED AND IS PRESUMED DEAD.
BUT WE NEVER SEE HER FUNERAL.
>> YOU SEE LURCH WITH A
DIFFERENT EYE COLOR. WHAT IF
WEEMS IS ALIVE BUT IN THE FORM
OF LURCH?
>> THIS THEORY SPECULATES A NEW
MEMBER OF THE ADDAMS FAMILY
WILL BE INTRODUCED.
>> THIS, IS.
>> TRUE!
>> BUT WE DON'T KNOW WHO IT IS.
>> IT IS ONE OF THE GREAT
ADDAMS FAMILY MYSTERY.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO SEE COUSIN
IT.
>> I WANT GRANDMA.
>> BE CAREFUL WHAT YOU WISH
FOR.
>> THOSE WERE AMAZING THEORIES.
>> DID WE MISS ANY?
>> TELL US YOUR THEORIES AND
REACTIONS IN THE COMMENTS?
>> NOW IF YOU'LL EXCUSE ME, I
HAVE HOMEWORK TO FINISH.
>>> HI EVERYBODY, HOW WE DOING?
BRAZIL? I CANNOT BELIEVE THAT I
GET TO INTRODUCE THE NEXT TRIO.
WE HAVE ONE OF THE MOST ICONIC
FILM MAKER OF ALL TIME. THE
DIRECTOR BEHIND THE LEGENDARY
FILM SUCH AS "300", "MAN OF
STEEL," ARMY OF THE DEAD. HERE
WITH HIS PRODUCER AND STAR OF
HIS FILM COMING TO NETFLIX IN
DECEMBER, GET READY. THIS THING
WILL BLOW YOUR MIND. HERE ARE
ZACK SNYDER, DEBORAH SNYDER,
AND SOFIA BOUTELLA!
>> THANK YOU, CHASE! AND THANK
YOU TUDUM! IT'S AWESOME TO BE
HERE! TALK ABOUT "REBEL MOON" A
LITTLE BIT.
>> HELLO, BRAZIL! WE ARE SO
HAPPY TO BE BACK IN BRAZIL
BECAUSE YOU GUYS ARE SOME OF
THE BEST FANS IN THE WORLD.
>> OH, LOOK AT THAT. IT'S
ALMOST LIKE BEING ONSET.
>> WOW, LOOK AT THAT, HUGE LED.
SOFIA, TELL US WHAT WILL BE ON
THE ACTUAL SET OF "REBEL MOON."
>> NOT ONLY DID I HAVE THE
CHANCE TO WORK WITH ZACK WHO IS
A TALENTED, FUN, PASSIONAL,
ENTHUSIASTIC DIRECTOR BUT I HAD
THE CHANCE TO WORK ON A WIDELY
TALENTED CAST THAT ZACK HAS
BEEN WORKING ON 20 YEARS. SO
MUCH HUMANITY, SO RELATABLE.
CONSIDERING ALL THE FANTASY AND
THE MAGIC TO IT. WE HAVE THE
CHANCE TO DEVELOP OUR
CHARACTERS WITH INCREDIBLE
TEAMS AND COSTUME AND MAKE UP
THAT MADE THIS PROCESS FUN AND
EXCITING. I ALSO HAD THE CHANCE
TO IMMERSE MYSELF INTO SETS
THAT WERE REAL, LIVE, AND
GIGANTIC. ALL THESE ASPECTS
COMBINED, ONLY ENCOURAGED AND
ELEVATED OUR PERFORMANCES TO
TELL THE AMAZING STORY TO THE
BEST OF OUR ABILITY! OKAY,
ZACK, TELL US, TELL EVERYONE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW THIS FILM
CAME TO BE AND WHY IT'S SO
SPECIAL TO YOU.
>> HEY GUYS. SO I HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS STORY QUITE A
WHILE. IT'S ABOUT A GROUP OF
FARMERS ON THE EDGE OF THE
GALAXY THAT GET VISITED BY THE
ARMIES OF THE MOTHER WORLD,
WHICH ARE THE BAD GUYS AND THE
FARMERS HAVE TO DECIDE WHETHER
TO FIGHT OR SUBMIT. AND YOU
KNOW, OF COURSE, I DON'T WANT
TO GIVE IT ALL AWAY. BUT IF
THEY HAD DECIDED TO FIGHT,
LET'S SAY THAT WAS AN OPTION.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO TRAVEL
AROUND THE GALAXY TO FIND
WARRIORS TO FIGHT WITH THEM.
AND SO, THAT HAD US TRAVELING
QUITE A BIT. AND DEBBIE, MY
INCREDIBLE WIFE AND PRODUCING
PARTNER, TELL US A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
LIKE MAKING THIS WORLD.
>> WELL I THINK THERE IS AN
EXPECTATION IN A ZACK SNYDER
FILM TO HAVE KICK ASS ACTION.
AMAZING VISUAL EFFECTS. AND
EXTRAORDINARY WORLD BUILDING.
AND "REBEL MOON" HAS IT ALL. WE
WORKED SO HARD ON BUILDING THIS
WORLD THAT TAKES YOU TO
DIFFERENT PLANETS. THERE WILL
BE LOTS OF DIFFERENT CREATURES.
BUT AT ITS HEART, IT'S STILL
GROUNDED AND IT IS REALLY VERY
MUCH A HERO'S JOURNEY ABOUT
THESE BROKEN HEROS AND THEY
FIND OUT WHO THEY REALLY ARE
ALONG THE WAY.
>> I HAVE NEVER BEEN PART OF
SOMETHING QUITE LIKE THIS
BEFORE. THE WORLD THAT ZACK HAS
BUILT IS SO RICH AND
SPECTACULAR.
>> AND I THINK WE HAVE
SOMETHING TO SHOW YOU GUYS, DO
YOU WANT TO SEE A LITTLE SNEAK
PEEK? ALL RIGHT, LET'S PLAY IT!
>> ALL RIGHT, SO HERE WE GO. A
LITTLE EXCLUSIVE BEHIND THE
SCENES, "REBEL MOON." I THINK
I'M SUPPOSED TO SAY ROLL IT OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. BUT YEAH,
ROLL IT! THANK YOU GUYS!
>> I THOUGHT I KNEW WHAT A BIG
MOVIE WAS UNTIL I CAME ON TO
THIS.
>> THIS MOVIE FOR ME EXISTED
ELEMENTALLY FOR 20 YEARS. IT'S
THE STORY OF A FEW AGAINST
MANY. IMPOSSIBLE ODDS. GOOD
VERSUS EVIL. I'M GETTING A
CHANCE TO TELL A STORY I HAVE
BEEN THINKING ABOUT FOR QUITE A
WHILE.
>> I WAS REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
ZACK. I JUST REALLY VALUE AND
ADMIRE HIS ENTHUSIASM FOR THE
CRAFT.
>> I HADN'T QUITE ANTICIPATED
THE PHYSICAL REQUIREMENTS OF
THIS.
>> WE HAD A SOLID TWO MONTHS OF
PREPARING THE BODY TO GET TO
THAT PLACE. I HAVE NEVER
TRAINED THAT MUCH.
>> I MEAN, IT'S GARGANTUAN.
>> I JUST REALLY WANTED TO MAKE
A GIANT ATMOSPHERIC IN SPACE
ADVENTURE.
>> IT IS SO, SO, SO BIG. SO
AMBITIOUS.
>> WE GET TO TRAVERSE THE
DARKER CORNERS OF THIS
UNIVERSE.
>> WE'LL HAVE A HUGE
ANTICIPATION FOR THIS FILM.
IT'S AMAZING.
>> SOMETHING SO POWERFUL THAT
YOU JUST WANT MORE. AND IT'S
ONLY THE BEGINNING.
>>> HELLO SAO PAULO, IT IS
ADMIRAL ATTICUS NOBLE. LOYAL
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE SLAIN
KING AND BALISARIUS. REGENT OF
THE IMPERIUM. I WELCOME THIS
PLANET INTO HIS WARM EMBRACE. I
SEE YOU'RE IN THE MIDST OF A
JOYOUS CELEBRATION. HOWEVER
THIS EVENT IS ENTIRELY
UNSANCTIONED AND UNAUTHORIZED
BY THE MOTHER WORLD. LET THIS
SERVE AS A WARNING THAT ALL
FUTURE GATHERINGS WILL BE DEALT
WITH AS DIRECT ACTS OF
REBELLION AND DEALT WITH
SWIFTLY. ANYWHERE. AT ANY
MOMENT. HAVE I MADE MYSELF
CLEAR? GOOD.
>> HMMM. IS IT JUST ME OR IS
ANYONE ELSE FEELING A LITTLE
PIRATEY? IT IS TIME TO SEEK THE
"ONE PIECE"! GUYS, THE BUZZ FOR
THIS SHOW HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY
DEAFENING AND IT IS ABOUT TO
GET EVEN LOUDER. SO MAKE SOME
NOISE TO THE CAST OF "ONE
PIECE"! INAKI GODOY , MACKENYU,
EMILY  RUDD, JACOB ROMERO
GIBSON, AND TAZ SKYLAR.
>> HELLO BRAZIL!
>> LOOK AT YOU! WOW!
>> OH MY GOD!
>> YOU GOT A STRAW HAT RIGHT
THERE.
>> WOW.
>> GUYS. WOW. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MAISA FOR THIS WONDERFUL
INTRODUCTION. HELLO TUDUM!
>> AND HELLO TO THE FANS OF
"ONE PIECE"!
>> I KNOW YOU ALL KNOW THIS.
BUT WE HAVE ALL BEEN WAITING
FOR THIS MOMENT FOR SUCH A LONG
TIME. GUYS, WELL, I'M THRILLED
THAT THE MOMENT HAS FINALLY
ARRIVED. ALONG WITH YOUR ICONIC
SHIP, THE "GOING  MERRY." "ONE
PIECE" IS ONE OF THE MOST
TALKED ABOUT ADAPTATIONS AROUND
THE WORLD. THE EXCITEMENT IS
OVER THE TOP AND FANS ARE
ECSTATIC ABOUT SEEING THESE
CHARACTERS FINALLY COME TO LIFE
ON NETFLIX. INAKI, EMILY, HOW
DOES IT FEEL TO BE A PARTOVER
SOMETHING SO HUGE?
>> I HAVE GROWN UP WITH ANIME.
I HAVE BEEN AN ANIME LOVER
SINCE I WAS A KID AND BEING A
PART OF "ONE PIECE" HAS TRULY
BEEN A DREAM FOR ME. AND GOD, I
DON'T WANT TO CRY. I FEEL SO
LUCKY TO BE LIVING MY DREAM AND
I CANNOT WAIT FOR YOU GUYS TO
SEE THE DREAM COME TO LIFE!
>> LET'S GO!
>> GUYS, THIS IS A DREAM COME
TRUE. I AM VERY HAPPY TO BE
HERE IN BRAZIL AND I KNOW THAT
LUFFIE IS SO EXCITED TO BE HERE
IN BRAZIL, TOO.
>> MACKENYU, THE WORLD OF "ONE
PIECE" IS MASSIVE AND THE STORY
SPANS DECADES. HOW WOULD YOU
DESCRIBE IT IN ONE SENTENCE?
>> I CAN'T EVEN HEAR THE
QUESTION. IT IS ABOUT A JOURNEY
TO FINDING THE BIGGEST TREASURE
IN THE WORLD. "ONE PIECE" WITH
US. FUFFY, ZORO, NAMI, USOPP,
SANJI.
>> AND TELL US A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT YOUR CHARACTER.
>> WELL I PLAY MONKEY D. LUFFY.
A YOUNG MAN WITH A BIG DREAM TO
SAIL AROUND THE WORLD WITH HIS
NAKAMAS. FIND THE ULTIMATE
TREASURE. THE "ONE PIECE." AND
BECOME THE KING.
>> I PLAY RORONOA ZORO. A
DEADLY PIRATE HUNTER DEDICATED
TO BECOME THE WORLD'S GREATEST
SWORDS MAN.
>> I PLAY NAMI. SHE'S A CLEVER
LITTLE CAT BURGLAR WHO IS VERY
GOOD WITH A BO STAFF AND SHE
HAS A COUPLE OF SECRETS AS WELL
AND COMES ALONG WITH THESE BOYS
AND KEEPS THEM IN LINE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> I'M JACOB. I PLAY THE
LEGENDARY CAPTAIN  USOPP. ONE
DAY I WILL BE A GREAT WARRIOR
OF THE SEA AND I WILL SAY JUST
ABOUT ANYTHING IF IT HELPS SAVE
THE PEOPLE I CARE ABOUT. YOU
KNOW.
>> I'M TAZ. AND I PLAY SANJI.
A CHEF WITH A FIERCE KICK WHO
DREAMS OF FINDING THE ALL BLUE!
TOGETHER, WE  ARE THE STRAW HAT
PIRATES. WE TRAVEL AROUND THE
SEAS SEARCHING FOR THE ONE
PIECE AND I ACTUALLY SEE SOME
STRAW HATS HERE, TOO. SO, TELL
ME. IF YOU ARE PART OF THE
STRAW HATS, CAN I GET A BIG
WOOOOO!
>> GUYS, BRAZIL LOVES YOU.
>> I LOVE BRAZIL!
>> WE LOVE YOU BRAZIL!
>> WE LOVE BRAZIL!
>> I KNOW THAT I HAVE SAID IT
BEFORE BUT I'LL SAY IT AGAIN.
THE FANS OF "ONE PIECE" ARE SO
INCREDIBLY DEVOTED TO THIS EPIC
STORY. SO IS THERE ANYTHING YOU
WANT TO SAY TO ALL THE FANS OF
"ONE PIECE"?
>> WELL, THIS STORY MEANS THE
WORLD TO ME. I FEEL SO HONORED
TO BE YOUR LUFFEY AND BE ABLE
TO TELL THIS STORY. THANK YOU
BRAZIL AND ENJOY THE RIDE!
>> AND NOW, WE GOT SOMETHING
REALLY SPECIAL FOR EVERYONE
HERE IN BRAZIL AND AROUND THE
WORLD TO SEE. IT'S NEVER BEEN
SEEN BEFORE IN PUBLIC UNTIL
TONIGHT.
>> WE ARE SO EXCITED TO UNVEIL
THE VERY FIRST LOOK AT "ONE
PIECE ! " ON BEHALF OF EVERYONE
AT NETFLIX, THE AMAZING
VISIONARY GENIUS ORO-SENSEI,
PLEASE ENJOY THIS TEASER FOR
THE ONE PIECE LIVE ACTION AND
SEE YOU ALL ON THE EAST BLUE
VERY SOON. IT STARTS AUGUST
31st. ROLL THAT CLIP! LET'S GO.
>> LUFFY, LUFFY, LUFFY, LUFFY!
ONE PIECE, ONE  PIECE ONE PIECE
ONE PIECE ONE PIECE ONE PIECE!
NOW? PLAY.
>> WILL Y'ALL TAKE A SELFIE
WITH US REAL QUICK? SAY ONE
PIECE!
>> YAY!
>>> EVER SINCE I WAS A KID, THE
SEA'S BEEN CALLING. SO, I'M
SETTING OUT TO FOLLOW MY
DREAMS. I'M GOING TO BE KING OF
THE PIRATES. ALL I NEED IS A
LOYAL CREW. AND I THINK
TOGETHER WE'D MAKE A PRETTY
GOOD TEAM.
>> WE ARE HEADING UP TO THE
GRAND LINE.
>> A TREACHEROUS STRETCH OF
OCEAN. WITH BIGGER ISLANDS AND
BIGGER PIRATES. CAREFUL WITH
THAT.
>> I DON'T WORK FOR YOU.
>> I'M SENSING A LITTLE BIT OF
TENSION AMONGST THE CREW.
>> NOT A CREW!
>> WE HAVEN'T SAILED TOGETHER
FOR VERY LONG. BUT I KNOW WE'VE
GOT EACH OTHER'S BACKS.
>> GUM GUM! PISTOL!
>> ALL GREAT FIGHTERS CALL OUT
THEIR FINISHING MOVES.
>> NO THEY DON'T.
>> STILL TO COME, STRANGER
THINGS!
>>> WOW, OKAY, SO OUR NEXT
GUEST NEEDS NO INTRODUCTION.
BUT HONESTLY, I'M SO PUMPED I'M
GOING TO INTRODUCE HIM ANYWAYS.
HE IS MY HERO AND HE IS
ABSOLUTELY YOURS. OUR FAVORITE
ACTION STAR IS BACK. NOT ONLY
DOES HE HAVE A NEW NETFLIX DOCU
SERIES CALLED ARNOLD BUT HE
RELEASED HIS FIRST TV SHOW EVER
CALLED FUBAR. THE NEW CHIEF OF
ACTION OFFICER AT NETFLIX. HE
IS CONTINUING TO CRUSH IT. BUT
ARE WE REALLY SURPRISED?
EVERYBODY, LET'S HEAR IT FOR
THE MAN, THE MYTH, THE LEGEND,
ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER!
>> HELLO BRAZIL! THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU CHASE
FOR THE WONDERFUL INTRODUCTION.
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU, I
ALWAYS LOVE COMING BACK TO
BRAZIL. I HAVE BEEN HERE COMING
TO BRAZIL FOR THE LAST 50
YEARS. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I HAVE COME HERE TO
BRAZIL FOR THE LAST 50 YEARS I
HAVE BEEN HERE PROMOTING BOD DI
BUILDING AND MY BOOKS,
VACATION, COMING TO THE AMAZON
WITH MY FRIEND AND DIRECTOR
JAMES CAMERON. AND I COME HERE
ALL THE TIME TO SEE ALL OF THE
FANTASTIC ATHLETES.
BODYBUILDERS AND FITNESS WOMEN.
THE WORLD'S STRONGEST MEN AT
THE FITNESS FESTIVAL RIGHT HERE
IN BRAZIL. IT IS ALWAYS
WONDERFUL TO COME BACK HERE. I
HAVE EVEN BEEN AT YOUR
CARNIVALE FOUR TIMES. I'M
ADDICTED TO BRAZIL. I LOVE
BRAZIL. BUT MOST OF ALL, I LOVE
THE BRAZILIAN FANS. YOU GUYS,
YOU GUYS HAVE THE GREATEST
ENERGY. YOU ARE SO
UNBELIEVABLE, SO LOYAL, I JUST
LOVE YOU GUYS. AND I'M HERE
TODAY FOR MY NETFLIX SHOW
"FUBAR." YES. "FUBAR." FANS
HAVE BEEN ASKING ME FOR YEARS
FOR ANOTHER GREAT ACTION
COMEDY. AND NOW, HERE IT IS
FINALLY. COULDN'T BE MORE
THRILLED WITH THIS FILM AND
WITH THIS TV SERIES. EIGHT
EPISODE SERIES. AT THE BEST
TIME MAKING "FUBAR," I TELL
YOU, THERE WERE LOTS OF LAUGHS
AND PLENTY OF KICK AZZ ACTION
AND FIGHT SCENES AND SHOOT-OUTS
AND CHASE SCENES AND ALL OF
THOSE THINGS. BUT IT IS ALSO
STORY ABOUT A FAMILY THAT I
THINK EVERYONE HERE CAN RELATE
TO. EVEN IF YOU ARE NOT THE
FATHER DAUGHTER SPY DUO. I
UNDERSTAND THAT. BUT THE ACTION
SCENES FELT LIKE COMING HOME. I
JUST LOVE THE ACTION SCENES BUT
MY FAVORITE PART OF THE SHOW IS
THAT IT FELT LIKE SOME OF MY
FAVORITE ACTION COMEDIES THAT I
HAVE DONE IN MY HISTORY. BUT
YOU HAVE BIG ACTION AND BIG
CHASE SCENES AND THEN RIGHT
AFTER THAT IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING IS JOKES AND
LAUGHTER. THIS IS WHAT THIS
SHOW IS ALL ABOUT. ACTION AND
LAUGHTER AND COMIC RELIEF AND
ALL OF THOSE THINGS. IT HAS
EVERYTHING IN THERE.
EVERYTHING. AND I TELL YOU,
NONE OF THIS YOU CAN DO BY
YOURSELF. I COULDN'T DO THIS BY
MYSELF. I COULDN'T DO THIS
ALONE. I HAD AN AMAZING
HILARIOUS CAST. A FANTASTIC
CAST. YOU ALL BECAME INCREDIBLY
CLOSE ON THE SET. THERE WAS
THIS WONDERFUL KIND OF
CHEMISTRY AMONG ALL OF US. AND
IT BECAME LIKE FAMILY. WE HAD
SO MUCH FUN MAKING THIS SHOW. I
TELL YOU, SO I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO THE
CAST, TO THE EXTRAORDINARY
CAST. THANK YOU SO MUCH TO THE
CREW. THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
NETFLIX FOR BELIEVING IN US.
AND THANK YOU TO THE FANS FOR
WATCHING IT. WATCHING IT HERE
IN BRAZIL. WATCHING IT AROUND
THE WORLD. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND NOW, NOW THAT "FUBAR" IS
OUT, WE HAVE BEEN IN THE TOP
FIVE FOR THE LAST FOUR WEEKS.
THINK ABOUT THAT. WHAT A
SUCCESS THIS SHOW IS BECAUSE OF
YOU FANS, BECAUSE YOU ARE THE
FANS. AND I HAVE BEEN BLOWN
AWAY BY THE LOVE OF ALL OF YOU.
IT'S BEEN INCREDIBLE HEARING
FROM ALL OF YOU. HEARING YOUR
SUPPORT OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
AND, THE SUPPORT OF THE FANS
ALL OVER THE WORLD. YOU KNOW, I
GET ASKED ALL THE TIME, BECAUSE
I'M NOW, YES, 75 YEARS OLD. SO
I GET ASKED ALL THE TIME.
ARNOLD. YOU'RE 75 YEARS OLD.
WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO RETIRE?
AND I SAY TO THEM ACTION HEROS
DON'T RETIREMENT THEY JUST
RELOAD. WE JUST RELOAD! TODAY,
I'M NOT JUST HERE AS AN ACTOR,
THE LEADING MAN OF "FUBAR," BUT
I'M ALSO HERE AS NETFLIX'S
CHIEF ACTION OFFICER. THAT'S
RIGHT. AND BECAUSE I'M THE
CHIEF ACTION OFFICER, I GET TO
ANNOUNCE OTHER PROJECTS. THERE
IS ONE THING THAT I OFFICIALLY
WANT TO FIRST ANNOUNCE IS THAT
WE ARE RENEWING "FUBAR" FOR
ANOTHER SEASON. THERE WILL BE A
SEASON NUMBER TWO. YOU KNOW HOW
MUCH  I LOVE SEQUELS. I LOVE
SEQUELS. SO WE ARE BACK, BABY.
WE'RE BACK! IT HAS BEEN REALLY
HEARTWARMING TO SEE JUST HOW
MUCH EVERYONE IS LOVING
"FUBAR." SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NOW, I CAN'T TELL YOU
MUCH ABOUT SEASON NUMBER TWO.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT IT
WILL BE FILLED AGAIN WITH
ACTION AND WITH COMEDY AND WITH
EXPLOSIONS AND WITH CHASE
SCENES AND FIGHT SCENES AND
SHOOT-OUTS AND ALL OF THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS. AND MAYBE EVEN
GET TO THE CHOPPER! AND NOW,
I'M GOING TO GO AND GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF A SNEAK PREVIEW.
A SNEAK PEEK INTO WHAT THINGS
ARE GOING ON BEHIND THE SCENES
BECAUSE SOMETIME, WHEN WE DO
THESE SCENES, IT DOESN'T ALWAYS
END UP PERFECT. THE ACTION
SCENES ARE NOT ALWAYS PERFECT.
SOMETIMES WE MAKE MISTAKES WHEN
WE DELIVER THE LINES. SO I WANT
TO SHOW YOU A LITTLE BIT OF
THOSE BLOOPERS. LET'S SHOW THEM
SOME OF THE BLOOPERS FROM
BEHIND THE SCENES OF "FUBAR"
NOW. AND DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
I WILL BE RIGHT BACK, OKAY? SO
WATCH THIS VIDEO.
>> ARNOLD!
>> WHY IS THE SAFE HOUSE
DIRECTLY ACROSS THE STREET FROM
THE SAME FLEA-RIDDEN HOTEL FROM
WHERE DIANA AND I MADE SWEATY
GRECIAN LOVE FOR 12 HOURS?
>> NO, DADDY!
>> LOOK AT THIS HOSTILITY.
>> OH, I'M HOSTILE? REALLY?
REALLY?
>> BRUNNERS, PLEASE.
>> YEAH, FAIR ENOUGH.
>> JESSE, ARE YOU GOOD?
>> WE'RE GOOD.
>> ALL THAT TIME IN SARDOVIA.
BORO PALONIA. NO?
>> YO.
>> I JUST SORT OF,UP YEP.
>> DID HE [BLEEP] UP JUST THE
WALK?
>> SURE DID.
>> ANOTHER ONE IN THE CAN. THE
MAN.
>> RELOAD.
>> EASY FOR YOU TO SAY.
>> I HOPE I LOOKED AS SEXY AS I
FELT.
>> CAN WE HAVE A MINUTE TO
THINK ABOUT THIS? WITHOUT YOU
TELLING ME WHAT TO DO? DID IT
STALL?
>> I'LL BE THE LAST ACTION
HERO.
>> GOOD.
>> COME ON.
>> I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A
STRAIGHT A STUDENT. FIRST YEAR
VIOLIN. NO SMOKE, TO DRINKING,
NO CURSING. [BLEEP] YOU.
>> TODAY IS A FLUFFY [BLEEP]
DAY.
>> WHAT?
>> HOLY [BLEEP].
>> WHAT THE [BLEEP]
>> HOW IS MY [BLEEP] [BLEEP]
>> [BLEEP] IT.
>> HOLY [BLEEP].
>> NO!
>> OH [BLEEP]
>> OH, CASUALLY JUST.
>> MY STYLE.
>> I TOLD YOU I'D BE BACK.
WELL, I HAVE A BIG SURPRISE FOR
ALL OF YOU TONIGHT. I'M EXCITED
THAT I CAN ANNOUNCE THAT MY OLD
FRIEND, A FANTASTIC ACTRESS, A
BADASS IS JOINING THE NETFLIX
FAMILY. IN ONE OF MY FAVORITE
SHOWS. AND I KNOW YOU WILL LOVE
THE SHOW TOO. SHE IS IN THE
VIDEO AND I WANT YOU TO WATCH
THIS VIDEO. SO ENJOY YOUR TIME.
AND HAVE A GREAT, GREAT
WEEKEND. OKAY? BYE BYE. SEE YOU
ALL. HASTA LA VISTA!
, HEY ARNOLD, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR GETTING THIS VIDEO TO
TUDUM. I'M LINDA HAMILTON AND
I'M SO EXCITED TO SHARE THIS
NEWS WITH YOU. I'M JOINING THE
CAST FOR STRANGER THINGS 5.
>> I'M GOING TO WORK ON THAT.
GOOD TO SEE YOU ARNOLD, LET'S
GET DINNER SOON AND EVERYONE
ELSE, I'LL SEE YOU FROM
HAWKINS.
>> SO, WE HAVE YOUR POSITION ON
THE FLOOR OVER HERE.
>>> STONE?
>> STONE!
>> OI BRAZIL!
>> WOW.
>> OI BRAZIL!
>> WOW! WOW!
>> HI YOU GUYS!
>> HI GUYS!
>> HELLO BRAZIL.
>> WOW.
>> WOO! I WANT TO START BY
SAYING THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
I WANT TO TELL ALL OF YOU, WE
LOVE YOU SO MUCH! THANK YOU!
THANK YOU! WOW! HOW WAS THAT
FOR TUDUM, HUH?
>> PRETTY CRAZY.
>> HELLO BRAZIL.
>> OI, BRAZIL!
>> WHAT AN AMAZE ING WAY. WE
LOVE  YOU, TOO. WHAT AN AMAZING
WAY WHAT AN AMAZING WAY TO
INTRODUCE THE FILM.
>> IT GRAPPLES WITH FINDING
HUMANITY.
>> MY CHARACTER IS AFTER WHAT
WE CALL THE HEART. AN
INCREDIBLY POWERFUL AI THAT CAN
PREDICT THE FUTURE AS YOU SEE
HERE.
>> RACHEL STONE HAS TO PROTECT
HER COVER AS AN MI6 AGENT
ALONGSIDE PARKER AND THE REST
OF THE TEAM. WHILE WORKING TO
FIND AND STOP KEYA.
>> AND THE FATE OF THE WORLD
DEPENDS ON WHO GETS THE HEART
FIRST.
>> OH MY GOSH, THIS MOVIE IS
TRULY INCREDIBLE. IT IS
INTENSE. THERE ARE SO MANY
INCREDIBLE ACTION SEQUENCES.
>> AND STUNNING LOCATIONS
AROUND THE WORLD.
>> TRUE.
>> AND A GREAT CAST IF I DO SO
MYSELF.
>> OH, THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME. PLEASE DO,
PLEASE DO. WE HAD AN INCREDIBLE
TIME SHOOTING THIS MOVIE WITH
OUR AMAZING CAST AND CREW.
WHICH MAKES ME WONDER IF YOU,
JAMIE, JAMIE?
>> SORRY.
>> DO YOU HAVE, LIKE, A
FAVORITE MOMENT YOU CAN RECALL
FROM SHOOTING THIS FILM?
>> TO BE HONEST, I THINK THE
ENTIRETY OF MAKING THIS FILM
WITH YOU GUYS, GETTING TO
TRAVEL THE WORLD, PUT ALL OF
OUR LOVE AND EFFORT INTO THIS
MOVIE. I LOVE YOU TOO. THERE IS
SO MUCH ACTION IN THIS MOVIE.
THERE IS SO MUCH EXCITEMENT IN
IT. WE CANNOT WAIT TO SHOW THIS
MOVIE TO YOU. I LOVE YOU.
>> OKAY, SO THIS MOVIE TAKES
PLACE LITERALLY ALL OVER THE
WORLD. OKAY FROM THE ITALIAN
ALPS TO THE SAHARA DESERT TO
ICELAND. GAL.
>> YES?
>> WHAT WAS YOUR FAVORITE
LOCATION?
>> HONESTLY, FIRST OF ALL, IF
EVERYONE IS GOING TO WATCH THIS
MOVIE AND WE GET LUCKY TO SHOOT
ANOTHER MOVIE, I THINK WE KNOW
WHERE THE NEXT MOVIE IS GOING
TO BE. I'M JUST SAYING. BUT
BETWEEN ICELAND AND ENGLAND AND
MOROCCO AND LISBON AND ALL THE
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS WE FILMED,
THEY ALL HAVE THEIR OWN MAGIC.
IT'S HARD TO CHOOSE.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> WE LOVE YOU. WE LOVE YOU.
RACHEL STONE MIGHT BE ONE OF MY
FAVORITE NEW ACTION STARS. WHAT
DO YOU THINK, ALIA, WHAT MAKES
RACHEL STONE SO SPECIAL?
>> WHAT MAKES RACHEL STONE
SPECIAL? OKAY. TOUGH ONE. OH,
THE FACT THAT SHE'S TOUGH. BUT
SHE IS ALSO SENSITIVE. THE FACT
THAT SHE IS SHARP, BUT SHE IS
ALSO SOFT AROUND THE EDGES.
BUT, WHAT I LOVE MOST ABOUT
RACHEL STONE IS THAT SHE IS A
WONDERFUL WOMAN!
>> OKAY, SO ON THAT WONDERFUL
NOTE, I THINK IT IS TIME TO
GIVE YOU A LITTLE TASTE OF WHAT
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT UP
HERE.
>> SO HERE IS THE OFFICIAL
WORLDWIDE DAY VIEW OF THE
TRAILER FOR "HEART OF STONE."
>> GOOD-BYE BRAZIL.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT YOU SIGNED UP
FOR.
>> NO FRIENDS, NO
RELATIONSHIPS. WHAT WE DO IS
TOO IMPORTANT. WHEN GOVERNMENTS
FAIL, THE ONLY THING LEFT IS
THE CHARTER.
>> THE MOST HIGHLY TRAINED
AGENTS.
>> NO POLITICAL LEANINGS. NO
NATIONAL ALLEGIANCES. WORKING
TOGETHER TO KEEP PEACE IN A
TURBULENT WORLD.
>> HOW MANY IN THE WELCOME
PARTY?
>> SIX OF THEM.
>> HARDLY SEEMS FAIR.
>> SHE DEVELOPING A SENSE OF
HUMOR?
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> HEY.
>> HEART IS WHAT GIVES THE
CHARTER ITS POWER. IT CAN CRUSH
A MARKET OR DROP A PLANE OUT OF
THE SKY. IF YOU OWN THE HEART,
YOU OWN THE WORLD.
>> JACK I NEED YOUR HELP.
>> PLOTTING EXIT ROUTES. WE'VE
BEEN BREACHED.
>> WHAT'S HAPPENING?
>> OUR SYSTEMS ARE OFFLINE.
>> WE'VE LOST THE HEART.
>> AND NOW YOU ANSWER TO ME.
>> YOU'RE COMPROMISED. DON'T
KNOW IF YOU COULD BE TRUSTED.
I'M STANDING YOU DOWN, RACHEL.
>> I DON'T CARE. WE HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT THEY ARE CAPABLE OF.
I NEED TO SHUT IT ALL DOWN.
>> SHOW TIME!
>> WOOH!
>> YOU THINK YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING. BUT THE WORLD IS
ABOUT TO SEE THE TRUTH.
>> HEART OR NO HEART, I'M
COMING FOR YOU.
>> CHANCE OF SUCCESS JUST
PLUMMETED.
>> ONLY CAUSE YOU'VE GOT NO
IMAGINATION.
>>> ALL RIGHT YOU GUYS, THAT IS
OUR SHOW EVERYONE.
>> I THINK YOU SAID YOU WANTED
TO TAKE YOUR SHOES OFF ON SAGE.
YOU WANTED TO DO THAT? LAST
MINUTE THING?
>> MY FEET HURT. MY VOICE IS
LOST.
>> IT WAS A DARE. IT WAS A
DARE.
>> DO IT. DO IT.
>> I DON'T CARE.
>> TAKING THEM OFF.
>> NO SHOES. WHO NEEDS THEM?
>> ALL RIGHT. ANYWAYS, BEFORE
CHASE TOTALLY EXPOSED ME, THANK
YOU TO ALL THE NETFLIX FANS
AROUND THE WORLD FOR WATCHING.
AND, OF COURSE, TO THIS
BEAUTIFUL CROWD OF LOVELY
PEOPLE FROM SAO PAULO.
>> DID YOU GUYS HAVE A GOOD
TIME AT TUDUM, 2023?
>> WHAT AN INCREDIBLE NIGHT IT
HAS BEEN WITH SO MANY SURPRISES
AND SO MANY APPEARANCES.
>> FROM NOT ONE, BUT TWO QUEEN
CHARLOTTES.
>> AND FOUR JOHN BOYEGAS.
>> AND THE WITCHER HIMSELF
HENRY CAVILL.
>> AND ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER
INTRODUCING HIS NEW SHOW
"FUBAR."
>> WHAT ABOUT ALL THE NEW
MASSIVE ACTION MOVIES COMING?
"HEART OF STONE," "LIFT,"
"REBEL MOON" AND "EXTRACTION 2"
AND "EXTRACTION 3" IN THE
WORKS.
>> AND OTHER SHOWS WE CAN'T
WAIT TO GET A GLIMPSE OF. LIKE
OUR FIRST EVER LOOK AT "ONE
PIECE." COME ON, ANIME, WEAVE
WITH ME, LET'S GO.
>> AND "AVATAR THE LAST AIR
BENDER."
>> AND "3 BODY PROBLEM."
>> OKAY, ALL RIGHT. YOU KNOW,
WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO RECAP ALL
OF NETFLIX'S AMAZING SERIES
RIGHT NOW. BUT, I DO HAVE TO
SAY I'M GOING TO MISS "NEVER
HAVE I EVER." GIVE IT UP FOR
"NEVER HAVE I EVER "Y'ALL. AND
ALSO, HOW EXCITED I AM TO SEE
THE NEW SEASON OF "DE VOLTA
AOS15".
>> THANK YOU! AND OF COURSE,
DON'T FORGET ABOUT SEASON FOUR
OF "OUTER BANKS."
>> THANK YOU AGAIN. TO ALL THE
FANS. FOR YOUR UNDYING LOVE AND
SUPPORT. YOU ARE THE REASON FOR
ALL OF THIS.
>> AND OF COURSE, DON'T FORGET
TO ADD ALL THESE NEW SHOWS AND
FILMS THAT YOU WANT TO SEE ONTO
YOUR OWN NETFLIX LIST.
>> WE'LL SEE YOU GUYS AGAIN
SOON, THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH!
>> MAKE TODAY'S EVENT LAST ALL
YEAR AT TUDUM.COM. NETFLIX'S
OFFICIAL HOME OF FANDOM.
>> INCREDIBLE LUCK.
>> NEWS, INTERVIEWS, VIDEOS AND
MORE. GO BEHIND THE STREAMS AT
TUDUM.COM.